[Musique]
Guillaume Pitron, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Guillaume Pitron, j'ai 39
ans, je suis journaliste, je réalise des
documentaires. Je travaille
essentiellément comme journaliste de
terrain, comme reporteur. Je ne crois
que ce que je vois. Donc, j'essaie de
ramener du terrain des observations qui
ont été vérifiées de mes yeux vus. Et
c'est ainsi que j'ai écrit en 2018,
enfin publié en 2018 un livre qui
s'appelle la guerre des métaux rares au
liens qui libère.
Avant ça, vous faisiez des petites
enquêtes sur le financement du
terrorisme.
Comment le le terrorisme se finance par
les matières premières ? Vous êtes
remonter loin
en fait mes études de droit, j'avais
comme spécialité
en DEA et dans mes études aux États-Unis
la question de la criminalité financière
et donc qui dit criminalité financière
dit blanchiment de capitaux et
financement du terrorisme. Or, il y
avait un certain nombre de
questionnements
dans les années 2000, au début des
années 2000 autour du financement de la
nébuleuse Al-Qaïda par un certain nombre
de matières premières. Je dis bien des
questionnements parce que ça n'a jamais
été forcément confirmé mais on pensait
que Al-Qaïda passait par le commerce de
matière première agricole au Yémen et et
au Soudan notamment la gomme arabique
souanaise figurez-vous et et que le
commerce de cette gomme arabite
notamment au Soudan passait par
était indirectement plus ou moins
directement contrôlé en partie par Ben
Laden qui était réfugié
au Soudan dans les années 90 et jusque
jus crois je crois au début des années
2000 et c'est ainsi je me suis intéressé
aux matières premières et donc en fait
je suis rentré dans le monde des
matières premières et donc des métorars
en tirant ce fil passionnant des
ressources.
Alors on va parler de ressources ce
soir, on va parler d'épuisement de
ressources, on va parler terra, on va
parler géopolitique des terras, on va
parler militarisation des terras, on va
parler tout un tas de sujets. On va
continuer juste le le sujet sur la
finance. La la criminalité en col blanc
euh ça donne quoi ? Les journalistes
d'investigation, vous pensez qu'ils ont
tous les éléments pour pouvoir aller
chercher ce qui se passe, faire sortir
de l'information ou c'est vraiment une
chappe de plomb sur ce qui se passe sur
les marchés financiers ? Est-ce que vous
connaissez les dark pool ? Est-ce que
vous connaissez ces ces ces choses-là ?
Dark pool al falloir que vous me allez
prendre ma place et c'est moi qui vous
interrogez. Non, je connais pas les dark
pool.
Alors, je suis journaliste mais en fait
en faisant du journalisme, je fais de la
géopolitique, de l'économie. Ça m'emmène
sur les questions économiques et
financières. Pour autant, je dois vous
dire que moi personnellement, je ne me
suis pas retrouvé à faire des enquêtes
comme pourrait les faire Denis Robert, à
me retrouver
impliqué dans les affaires comme
Clairstream où j'aurais pu avoir accès à
des informations et investiguer sur ce
type de de choses-là. Donc, j'ai du mal
à répondre précisément à votre question
de savoir si est-ce qu'il y a une chape
de plomb. Mais bon, je suis journaliste,
je reste quand même quelqu'un qui essaie
de de faire son métier aujourd'hui. Être
journaliste d'investigation, c'est rare.
Je dirais enfin journaliste qui fait de
l'enquête, c'est rare. C'est difficile
l'enquête, ça coûte énormément d'argent.
Quelque fois, vous pouvez passer des
semaines à chercher un chiffre et
encore, il faut recouper ce chiffre.
Donc c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
de faire du journalisme euh
d'interviewer
un politique où c'est plus compliqué que
dans certaines dans certains cas de
faire du journalisme qui consisterait à
faire du reportage.
Donc c'est vrai que c'est pas un métier
qui est très développé pour cette
raison. Et puis deuxièmement, vous avez
aussi une forme d'autocensure. Je veux
dire, vous touchez à des informations
qui peuvent être extrêmement sensibles,
qui peuvent toucher à des milieux qui ne
veulent pas que du bien lorsque vous
parlez d'eux. Donc du coup aujourd'hui
cette chape de plomb, elle peut
quelquefois être une propre une
autocensure qu'on s'impose et qu'on et
donc on s'empêche en fait soi-même de
vouloir creuser plus loin ou de sortir
ce type d'information là parce que on se
doute queon est un peu seul face à ce
face à au monde sur lequel on enquête.
Je précise que beaucoup de journalistes
travaillent seuls et donc travaillent
dans un média comme le monde, un grand
média comme une grande chaîne qui a les
moyens de pouvoir vous protéger si
jamais il y a un problème y compris d'un
point de vue judiciaire juridique c'est
bien. Lorsque vous êtes tout seul et que
vous n'avez pas un média derrière vous
pour vous soutenir y compris d'un point
de vue médiatique euh qui plusait en
assurant des frais d'avocat si jamais
vous vous faites embêter, c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué. Or aujourd'hui, ce type
de journalisme est un journalisme qui se
pratique beaucoup seul. Donc ça fait
beaucoup de limitations à l'exercice de
ce métier.
On va revenir à notre sujet. Euh la
transition écologique, la transition
verte, c'est est-ce que c'est pas une
sémantique du bullshit pour reverdir le
capitalisme ? parce que infiné avec les
enquêtes que vous avez pu faire,
ça sonne pas un peu creux quand on nous
dit la technologie, la science vont nous
sauver de tous les périls comme
l'épuisement des ressources,
l'épuisement des métaux.
B
alors votre question amène à enfin à
essayer de savoir d'abord d'où l'on
vient. C'est-à-dire qu'on vient d'où on
vient d'un âge qu'on appelle enfin
thermoindustriel. C'est-à-dire qu'on
notre société est basée sur la
consommation de ressources fossiles à
commencer par le pétrole, le gaz, le
charbon et ces ressources permettent de
péréniser un système énergétique qui
lui-même est l'une des l'un des
fondements de du capitalisme et
simplement tout ceci pollue beaucoup et
donc c'est responsable d'émission de gaz
à effet de serre. Comme vous le savez,
le climat se réchauffe. Euh, il faut
qu'on limite qu'on passe pas à la barre
des 2 degrés de réchauffement climatique
d'ici 2100. C'est ce qui a été euh ce
qui a été convenu à la COP 21. Comme
vous le savez aussi, il y a déjà des
rapports y compris publiés par des
experts, des ingénieurs français tout
récemment qui disent que à ce rythme là,
on est plutôt on est en train d'aller
vers les 5 6 degrés de réchauffement
climatique à la fin du 21e siècle.
6 degrés de moyenne, mais sur les
continents ce sera plus.
Alors après, ça dépend des zones. Il y a
des zones où au contraire enfin il y
aura plus de de Oui, effectivement, il y
a des zones qui vont se réchauffer,
d'autres qui vont se refroidir aussi.
Donc en fait, ça dépend mais d'une man 5
6°gr C'est de moyenne
de moyenne
mais mais sur les continents ça va
chauffer beaucoup plus.
Alors du coup je sais alors faudit
peut-être prendre la Méditerranée par
exemple qui est une zone intéressante
qui va être particulièrement exposée à
ce réchauffement. Je connais pas la
moyenne sur la M dans zone
méditerranéenne particulièrement mais
visiblement la Méditerranée serait
particulièrement impactée et plus que la
moyenne justement que d'autres zones.
Mais donc si on veut passer dans
l'après-pétrole, il faut aller vers les
énergies vertes et c'est là qu'on
reboucle sur votre question. Et donc les
énergies vertes, cette façon de
présenter le la le cette technologie ou
du moins ce ce changement de de
paradigme en utilisant des technologies
propres, de l'énergie propre, de tout
qui est propre, est-ce que c'est je vais
je vais poser une question tout à fait
candide, mais quand on connaît le type
d'exploitation de terre rares, de métau
lourds, de métaux de choses comme ça,
quand on délocalise notre notre
pollution dans des pays avec des des
standards écologiques moindres ou des
standards sociaux ou moindre. Est-ce que
on ne s'achète pas une bonne conscience
pour faire des belles des belles pubs
pour dire voilà nous on est des
politiques, on travaille bien, on fait
une économie verte mais en fin de compte
dans cette société mondialisée, la
pollution est délocalisée chez les
pauvres la majeure partie du temps.
Mais en fin de compte, ça sert
strictement à rien et on consomme et on
pollue pire qu'avant. Moi quand
j'entends le mot vert, quand j'entends
le mot propre qui est associé à tout
parce que aujourd'hui on fait de la
viande propre, on parle aussi de viande
propre, la clean meat et la viande de
laboratoire qui va remplacer bah la la
viande de vache ou de je ne sais quel
autre animal élevé à la ferme. Et puis
on emploie le mot propre à tort et à
travers et le mot vert pour parler de la
mobilité, pour parler de la façon dont
on produit de l'énergie, pour produire
tout ça. Donc moi, c'est les mots qui
m'insupportent. C'est-à-dire que
maintenant que l'on sait ce qui peut y
avoir derrière le verre, quand j'entends
ça, forcément je pense green washing.
immédiatement. C'est le premier mot qui
me vient à l'esprit parce que rien n'est
propre, mais il y a toujours un impact
quelque part. Les économistes ditent
"There's no free lunch". Euh on on
déjeûne jamais gratuitement. Il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui va payer
l'adition. Et donc en fait, c'est vrai
que je suis euh revenu de cette de cet
idéalisme que je que je pouvais
d'ailleurs moi-même nourrir parce qu'il
fallait bien que je comprenne ce qu'il y
avait derrière ce mot-là. Et aujourd'hui
euh effectivement quand je regarde
toutes ces technologies et ce discours,
je vois quelques mots et je vois
quelques phénomènes que vous avez
évoqué. Je vois des conditions
d'extraction de matières premières et
notamment des matières premières
minérales qu'il faut bien aller chercher
quelque part, extraire, raffiner pour
ensuite les mettre dans toutes ces
technologies que l'on présente comme
vertes. Je vois des phénomènes de
délocalisation de pollution. C'est ce
que vous avez dit, c'est-à-dire que ce
sont des métaux qui ne se trouvent pas
dans notre enfin, ils se trouvent dans
notre sol. On pourrait tout à fait aller
extraire des métaux chez nous, mais on
ne veut pas les extraire chez nous.
Donc, on a fermé les mines, on a fermé
toutes les usines, voilà, des décennies
pour laisser ces mines et ces usines
ouvrir à l'autre bout du monde dans des
pays qui dégueulassent leur
environnement pour en fait nous fournir
ces matières premières d'un monde plus
vert. Et donc, ce sont d'autres pays qui
assument cette pollution à notre place.
Donc, on a délocalisé la pollution, on a
transféré la pollution de ces
technologies vertes et et digitales. On
croit qu'on est propre alors qu'en fait
on a s les autres. Mais d'un point de
vue comptable, on ne supporte pas
finalement le coût ne serait-ce que
comptable et les coûts concrets
matériels de cette pollution. Donc je
vois aussi ce phénomèneel là. Et donc je
vois et c'est pour conclure sur vos sur
vos remarques, un immense phénomène de
non seulement canashing mais aussi
d'hypocrisie et de bonne conscience
qu'on se donne à soi-même en se disant
"Regardez,
je vais mettre à la casse ma vieille
voiture qui consomme du diesel ou de
l'essence. Je vais m'acheter à la place
une voiture électrique qui va pas
émettre d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre quand je roule notamment dans une
ville. Je vais installer sur mon toit un
panneau solaire qui effectivement va
produire de l'électricité sans rejeter
de CO2. Très bien. Mais encore une fois
cette pollution, elle est tailleur, on
ne la voit pas et on se part d'un beau
discours vert et et en réalité et en
réalité on a juste fait que dégueulasser
les campagnes notamment chinoises pour
pouvoir être propre. Donc il y a cette
hypocrisie, il y a cette bonne
conscience qui est un leur en fait.
Alors c'est quoi de dégueulasser la
campagne chinoise ? Parce que
ouais bah vous êtes venu pour ça non ?
On voit beaucoup de personnes se draper
dans l'étendard de la vertu vert de la
vertu tout ça. Mais concrètement sur le
terrain ça donne quoi ? C'est des
villages contre cancer.
Euh j'ai j'ai voyagé en Argentine fut un
temps. Les gens me disaient que il y
avait énormément de de maladies, des
pollutions au mercure, des choses comme
ça. En Chine, c'est à peu près la même
chose ou c'est pire ?
C'est à peu près avoir pire que pire que
ça.
Ça ressemble à quoi ?
Bah en fait, ça ressemble à quoi ?
D'abord, ce que je peux vous dire, c'est
que ce que je vais vous dire, c'est des
choses qui se passent maintenant parce
que je réalise un documentaire pour euh
je coréalise,
il paye un peu. Non, il dessous.
Bah c'est toujours
mieux de travailler pour que de
travailler pour d'autres chaînes et ça
reste quand même des budgets qui sont
extrêmement conséquent par rapport à par
rapport à la réalisation d'un
documentaire pour une autre chaîne parce
que vous travaillez sur des projets de
90 minutes. Voilà, donc il y a quand
même des budgets. Ça vous permet d'aller
dans faire le tour du monde.
C'est combien le budget ?
Alors écoutez le budget pour il faudrait
je demande à mon producteur, je vais
peut-être l'appeler. Non, c'est à peu
près, je crois 200 et quelques 1000 €
240 2500 € si je me trompe pas mais ça
c'est le budget de la chaîne et vient
s'ajouter ensuite le budget d'autres
coproductions. C'est-à-dire que d'autres
chaînes étrangères peuvent dire j'entre
en coproduction avec et donc je mets un
peu d'argent au pot pour pouvoir ensuite
moi avoir la la primeur sur la diffusion
du film dans mon pays. Et puis vous avez
aussi des aides d'état. Vous avez le
CNC, vous avez la région je ne sais quoi
qui vous donne de l'aide. Donc à
l'arrivée, le budget total pour un
documentaire pour ce type de case là, ça
peut représenter
300 400000 € peut-être. Ouais. Donc vous
avez quand même un peu de moyens quand
vous êtes journaliste, même si votre
salaire de journaliste représente qu'une
part réduite de ce de ce salaire global
qui sert à financer les caméraman, les
preneurs son, les drones, les les
voyages parce qu'il faut faire le tour
du monde je ne sais combien de fois de
suite. Mais bon, au mieux de tout ça, il
y a quand même un salaire pour le
journaliste. Donc on on peut vivre de ce
métier même si c'est dur.
Donc concrètement sur le terrain, ça
ressemble à quoi Et donc je suis dans le
cas de ce documentaire en Chine il y a 6
mois, c'était en avril donc céit un peu
plus, c'était 8 mois, en avril mai, fin
avril, début mai. Et je suis dans ces
zones chinoises où on extrait ces
fameuses matières premières sur
lesquelles il n'est pas de monde plus
vert. Et je suis notamment dans l'elong
Djang. C'est une province au nord de la
Chine, la plus tombe trionale de la
Chine. Et je suis dans la zone de Ji.
C'est un petit village autour duquel en
fait on extrait beaucoup de ce graphite.
Il faut savoir que la Chine représente
70 % de la consommation mondiale, de la
production pardon mondiale de graphite.
Donc on est dans une des grosses zones
de production mondiale de ce minerai qui
est nécessaire pour vos téléphones
portables, qui est nécessaire pour les
batteries de vos voitures électriques.
Et ce graphite s'extrait dans des
conditions complètement dingues.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez bah des
mines. une mine, faut pas oublier que
c'est une entaille dans le sol et donc
c'est des c'est des cratères qu'on filme
notamment avec des drones pour prendre
la mesure de l'immensité de ces de ces
de ces zones d'extraction et puis ce le
la la la roche de laquelle on va
extraire le graphite va être ensuite
transféré dans des usines. Quand on les
regarde ces usines, c'est comme dans les
années 50, vous avez des hommes qui
travaillent dans ces usines avec des
fichus sur le sur le sur le sur le
visage et qui se protègent tant qu'ils
peuvent des poussières de graphite et
qui disent si jamais je porte pas ces
fichus, bah mes poumons vont devenir de
la pierre et cetera. Donc ça c'est la
réalité. Et puis des gens autour, des
villageois qui parlent et qui vous
disent le drame que ça peut être pour
eux de vivre dans ces zones extrêmement
polluées, mais ils ne peuvent rien dire,
ils ne peuvent rien faire. Je rappelle
qu'on est en Chine et que la liberté
d'expression en Chine c'est limitée. Et
la même zone à la même époque, je suis
en Mongolie intérieur euh au nord-ouest
de Pékin près de Baoutou où l'on extrait
où on et où l'on raffine sur tous les
terres rares. Et les zones de raffinage
de terror, c'est dystopique. Je je les
images parlent d'elles-mêmes, elles
seront elles seront elles seront
publiques bientôt. Les images, c'est des
lacs, enfin un des gigantesques lacs de
rejet toxique dans lequel on rejette
directement les eaux usées l'industrie
du raffinage. Des eaux qui contiennent
des métaux lourds, qui contiennent
divers résidus et en fait ce lac là des
gens vivent autour. On vous parle de
cancer, on vous parle de maladie des
autres verts. Rien n'est vraiment fait
pour stopper cette pollution là. et les
experts chinois des terrar sur place
vous disent euh quand le gouvernement
vient, on fait un peu propre et puis dès
que le représentant du gouvernement
central de tourner, on refait comme si
enfin on refait comme au bon vieux temps
et il n'y a aucune espèce de supervision
de la pollution générée par ces
activités et et vraiment ça fait partie
des zones. J'en ai fait pas mal des pays
dans ce métier. Je suis allé dans une
quarantaine de pays depuis 12 ans. Je
fais ce métier. J'ai vu la pollution. Je
l'attends, j'ai pas fait ce métier pour
voir la pollution, mais je l'ai vu, je
l'ai vu au-dessus des des des forêts de
palmiers en Indonésie lorsqu'on remplace
à feu près primaire par des monocultures
de palmier. Euh j'ai pu l'avir cette
pollution euh en Méditerranée en voyant
la pollution dingue générée sur les
littoraux de Méditerranée euh quand je
travaille pour France 3. La l'épisode le
plus impressionnant que j'ai qui m'a été
donné de voir, c'est cet épisode chinois
euh il y a 6 mois dans cette zone de
Baotou avec ces paysages dévastés par
les terres rares qui servent pour la
plupart des moteurs des voitures
électriques et pour nos téléphones
portables. Et ça fait partie des zones
les plus dystopiques. Je sais pas si on
peut parler de dystopie mais c'est pas
une dystopie parce que c'est la réalité,
ça se passe aujourd'hui. Et ça ça je
l'ai vécu et je peux vous dire que c'est
extrêmement impressionnant.
Les conditions de tournage en Chine
c'était comment ? Il fallait une
autorisation particulière ? Il vous avez
un visa, vous avez fait ça à l'arrache.
Vous avez fait ça comment ?
Euh
vous allez pas vis journaliste ou pas ?
Euh non.
Vous ne dites pas aux douers chinois
rentrant
à Pékin que vous allez dans les mines de
terre rares et de et de graphite. Donc
sinon il il vous en empêche.
Sinon vous reprenez le premier avion
dans le dans le sens inverse. Donc vous
rentrez à Paris, vous êtes à Paris sous
sous 12h. Donc bien évidemment que non.
Donc en fait, vous allez en Chine pour
constater des choses, pour les filmer
sans jamais être vu.
Et donc vous n'êtes jamais vu et je ne
suis jamais vu.
Et
euh la prise de conscience de l'Union
européenne par rapport à ça, ils font
quoi ? Ils tournent la tête, ils ont
fait des études sur notre future
consommation terra, ils ont fait des
études contre sur sur les répercussions
de de ça, sur les tensions
géopolitiques. On va rentrer un peu dans
le sujet là. le nous notre bon de
conscience
on roule en voiture verte tout va bien
tout se passe bien l'Union européenne
elle fait quoi derrière elle est
consciente de ça ? est pas consciente,
elle ferme les yeux, elle préfère
délocaliser la pollution, elle préfère
se mettre en laisse consciemment, se
mettre sous le le le bon vouloir chinois
parce que du jour au lendemain, ils
peuvent couper le le exportation comme
ils avaient fait sur le Japon fut. Les
États-Unis, je crois bien,
les Japons et les États-Unis.
Et euh on fait quoi ? Est-ce que est-ce
que vous avez senti que nos
institutions, nos politiques se
prenaient le sujet en main ? Est-ce
qu'ils veulent réouvrir des mines chez
nous avec une conscience plus propre ?
Est-ce qu'ils veulent
vous ouvrez d'immenses donc il y a deux
il y a deux niveaux de réponse à ce que
vous dites pour faire simple dans un
premier temps. D'abord la à la
Commission européenne, vous avez des tas
de gens qui sont parfaitement au courant
du sujet et vous avez à la Dig Grow, la
direction générale en charge des
questions économiques
de la Commission européenne à Bruxelles
toute une unité qu'on appelle la raw
material unit, l'unité de matière
première et qui s'intéresse
spécifiquement à ces questions de
matière rare, de matière critique.
Ils sont ils sont combien dans cette
unité ?
Ils sont une trentaine. Une je dirais
une trentaine environ. Alors
quel profil ?
Quel profil ? des économistes, des
juristes. Il y a également des de tous
les toutes les nationalités. Il y a des
Français, il y a des Belges, il y a des
Polonais, il y a des espagnols. Ce sont
des gens qui sont des fonctionnaires
européens et dont le job c'est de faire
le point sur ces matières premières
qu'ils appellent critiques. Critique, ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire pas rare
au sens géologique du terme, au sens où
ce serait des
il s'intéressent à des matières
premières qui sont pas forcément rares
parce que quelque fois on parle de méar
et on peut revenir sur la définition du
mot métaar mais ils s'intéressent à ce
qu'ils appellent les matières premières
critiques. Ça veut dire les matières qui
dont l'approvisionnement pourrait
manquer pour l'Union européenne. Donc
ils disent voilà compte tenu du fait que
c'est des métaux pour beaucoup d'entre
eux que l'on produit dans des quantités
bien moindres que si c'était des grands
métaux comme le fer, l'aluminium. compte
tenu du fait que euh il faut un outil
industriel particulièrement
complexe pour pouvoir les extraire, les
raffiner et que tout ça bah ça nécessite
des investissements lourds et contenu du
fait que la production de ces métaux est
concentrée dans des pays bien
particuliers et bien en fait il y a un
risque que les 28 bientôt 27 pays de
l'Union européenne et bien manquent à un
moment de ces métaux et qu'il y a une
pénurie de ces métaux. Alors c'est une
pénurie qui serait quoi ? une pénurie
limitée dans le temps et dans l'espace
parce qu'à un moment tel pays dit je
garde ces métaux pour ma propre pour mes
propres besoins ou parce que je les
vends à 100 % à un autre industriel qui
en a besoin pour une nouvelle
application technologique
révolutionnaire qui a besoin de 100 % de
la production de ce métal. Et pour ces
raisons-là et bien en fait il y a un
risque de pénurie qui encore une fois
est limité dans le temps et dans
l'espace mais qui fait que on les
appelle critiques. Et donc c'est la
notion de métau critique. Et les
fonctionnaires de la Commission
européenne il vous pondent à longueur
d'année des tas de rapports là-dessus et
je vous invite à aller les regarder sur
le site de la de la raw material unit de
la commission européenne des rapports
passionnants qui vous disent de quelle
matière première on parle. Quelque fois
des matières premières à école. Le
caoutchou figurez-vous est soumis. Il y
a un risque de pénurie sur le caoutchou.
De quelle matière ? Donc voilà. Ensuite,
pour quels usages ? Et puis quels sont
les pays qui tiennent l'essentiel de la
production de ces ressources ? Euh et
puis quelle est la politique
d'exportation de ces pays, quelle est sa
politique commerciale ? Et pour toutes
ces raisons, en fait, il y a une très
très bonne connaissance de ces enjeux
géopolitiques
de économiques autour des matières
premières critiques des métaux rares.
Après, il y a un niveau politique,
c'est-à-dire très bien, mais une fois
que moi dans mon bureau à la Commission
européenne, je sais ça et je reste
soumis au bon vouloir de mon N+1 et du
directeur général de ma de ma de ma de
ma branche et puis une fin de mon
commissaire et puis du président de la
commission ou de la présidente de la
commission. Et est-ce que le sujet est
politisé ? Pas vraiment. Je dirais pas
non parce que le sujet commence à être
politisé et on commence à pas mal en
parler. Ça monte aux États-Unis.
L'administration Trump est assez au fait
de ces sujets. Mais en quoi est-ce que
tous les warnings que je peux mettre sur
ces enjeux là touchent le politique qui
lui va politiser ces enjeux et décider
et bien de développer une politique
d'approvisionnement en ces matières
premières qui ne dépendent pas de la
Chine, d'aller sécuriser mes
approvisionnements ailleurs, pourquoi
pas d'ouvrir des mines éventuellement
en Europe en disant au moins c'est chez
nous et si nos champs de blé sont en
Europe et qu'on est content d'être
indépendant d'un point de vue
alimentaire, d'avoir une souveraineté
alimentaire autant être aussi souverain
d'un point de vue minéral et d'avoir
donc notre propre production pour
nous-même. Et donc c'est là que ça
pourrait devenir politique et que ça
pourrait faire une politique cohérente.
Là, je dois vous dire qu'il se passe pas
grand-chose. C'est quand même
relativement faible en terme de décision
politique pour dire je vais me sortir de
l'État chinois, je vais aller sécuriser
mes approvisionnements en Amérique
latine, ça se fait un peu mais pas
beaucoup et puis je vais aller ouvrir
des mines en Europe parce qu'en fait bah
c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut pour faire
notre transition énergétique. Ces sujets
ne sont pas porteurs politiquement.
Vous vous imaginez vous imaginez quand
même le risque politique que vous prenez
en tant que politique de dire ces
choses-là au consommateur qui n'a pas
envie de les entendre. Donc pour ces
raisons, ce n'est pas vraiment politisé.
Le le
risque, on sait tous pourquoi ils
veulent pas le prendre. parce que faire
des mines dégueulasses en Europe, c'est
ça ça passera pas bien. On va switcher
un petit peu le notre interview et on va
passer sur le les questions de de
d'anticipation des industriels face à
ça. Est-ce que le pouvoir industriel
prend des couvertures sur les terres
rares comme Elon Musk a pu le faire pour
son entreprise, c'est acheter des
contrats
au comptant pour sécuriser ses
approvisionnements. Est-ce que vous avez
senti le milieu de l'entreprise se
réveiller face au monde politique qui ne
veut pas le faire ? Alors, en fait, la
prise de conscience, elle démarre de
l'industriel et elle démarre depuis 2011
2010 parce qu'en fait vous l'avez pas,
vous l'avez évoqué, il y a eu un embargo
euh informel chinois sur les terres
rares qui est une classe de météau rar
euh à destination du Japon et des
États-Unis et il y a eu une espèce de
furée médiatique à cette époque autour
de ces de cet embargo parce qu'on a pris
conscience de notre vulnérabilité à la
Chine pour ces métaux qui sont
stratégiques. Je rappelle qu'en France,
il y a un comité des métaux
stratégiques, le Commerce qui dépend de
Bercy et il y a enfin le Commerce dresse
la liste des métaux stratégiques. Et je
peux vous assurer que les Terrars sont
parmi les plus stratégiques de ces
métaux. Et donc il y a cette prise de
conscience de l'industriel d'abord de
l'existence de ces métaux parce qu'en
fait il savait pas que ces métaux
existaient. C'estàd que dans une
bagnole, je ne vais pas citer lequel
industriel ne savait pas qu'il y avait
des terres rares dans sa bagnole. Donc
parce que pourquoi ? parce qu'en fait il
n'achète pas la terre rare, il achète le
produit fini ou semi-fini avec la terre
rare dedans. Et l'industriel en Europe,
il est en bout de chaîne. Il assemble
des produits semi-finis, des composants
mais dans lesquels il ne sait pas
forcément ce qu'il y a. Donc déjà
l'industriel, il a eu besoin de
connaître tout ça et de remonter à la
source de la matière pour faire le lien
entre la matière et ce qu'il achète. Et
puis après, ils se sont mis à se poser
des questions de sécurisation de ces
approvisionnements. Soit en allant tant
que faire ce peut négocier qui mandé
avec les Chinois quelques grammes
supplémentaires de terre rares et autres
mé rapporter la démocratie quand même.
Et puis c'est
les petits pays comme la République
démocratique du Congo, on leur apporte
la démocratie. Tout se passe bien. Les
Chinois, c'est plus compliqué, ils sont
plus nombreux. Non seulement c'est on
leur apportera pas on ne leur importera
pas nos valeurs et en plus de ça
on ne leur importera pas notre propre
définition du commerce international
telle qu'on voudrait l'avir. C'estd que
la définition que les Chinois ont du
commerce international est propre aux
Chinois de même que les Américains ont
leur définition propre qui correspond à
leurs intérêts bien compris et elle
n'est pas forcément cohérente avec
le libre échange de métau rares. Au
contraire les Chinois ne veulent pas
vendre ces métaux au résum parce qu'ils
veulent les garder pour eux. Donc allez
commander ces métaux à des Chinois qui
vous disent "Mais moi ces métaux, je les
garde pour moi, je les mets dans ma
batterie et je ne vous vends pas le
métal mais je vous vends la batterie qui
coûte très cher." Ça représente un sens
économique pour la Chine qui va du coup
remonter la chaîne de valeur et qui va
vendre ses produits beaucoup plus chers,
faire de la valeur ajoutée, proposer des
emplois mieux payés à 1 milliard de
Chinois qui ne demandent qu'à acheter
des téléphones Huawei à je ne sais
combien de de Yan pour regarder des
vidéos de chat dessus. C'est ça qu'il
faut faire tenir, cette machine qu'il
faut faire tenir en Chine. Donc le
Chinois ne va pas vous vendre des métau
rares, il va vous vendre le produit
semi-fini avec le métal à l'intérieur.
Le chinois, il vous dit quoi ? Il vous
dit "Vous les Français, vous vendez pas
du raisin, vous vendez du vin." Bah nous
les Chinois, on va pas vous vendre de
météau rares, on va vous vendre des
produits finis. Donc l'industriel, il
peut toujours essayer, ça va être
difficile. Donc il va aller
s'approvisionner ailleurs. Il regarde
son lithium en Australie, son lithium en
Amérique latine. Il va bien évidemment
s'intéresser au cobal congolais. Sauf
que manque de peau, les Chinois sont là
depuis bien longtemps et ils ont déjà en
fait mis la main sur 80 % du cobalt
congolais. Mais il y a pas que du cobalt
au Congo, il y en a aussi ailleurs. Donc
est-ce qu'on va aller chercher ça dans
d'autres pays ? Et puis l'industriel il
essaie de substituer, c'est-à-dire il
essaie de dire si il y a des terres
rares pour mon éolienne nécessaire pour
le retort de mon éolienne, une éolienne
de grande puissance peut nécessiter
jusqu'à 1 tonne de terre rare pour le
retort. Mais je peux peut-être remplacer
ce retort à base d'M permanent et dans
l'ément permanent, il y a une terre rare
et je le remplace par du cuivre, par un
par un par par un par un retort à base
de cuivre. Et donc en fait, je substitue
mon besoin de terre rar
métal qui est moins rare et qui se
trouve par exemple le chili comme le
cuivre. Et dans ce cas-là, je contourne
le problème chinois et du coup, je
sécurise mes approvisionnements avec un
pays comme le Chili qui, en fait, de
respect euh des règles du commerce
international est un petit peu plus
docile. Et donc, c'est de cette manière
que les industriels depuis bientôt 10
ans ont essayé de s'organiser pour
pouvoir contourner ce monopole chinois,
mais voilà, enfin, quasi monopole qui
reste quand même très fort sur des
métaux dont on rappelle qu'ils sont
stratégiques et non substituables.
Ils sont non substituables mais vous
venez de nous dire,
je viens de dire qu'ils étaient
substituables, excusez-moi. Donc en fait
en fait je me corrige, je précise, on
remplace difficilement un aimant de
terre rare par un autre aimant avec
autre chose qu'une terre rare. Dans un
de néonyme ferbor ou de samarium cobalt,
c'est difficile de remplacer le néonyme
ou le samarium qui sont des aimants des
des terres rares par une autre terre
rare ou par un autre métau par un autre
métal. C'est ça que je voulais dire par
non substituable. En revanche, on peut
substituer un aimant par quelque chose
qui n'est pas un aimant et ça devient un
retor bobiné à base de cuivre.
Excusez-moi, je rentre dans les détails
techniques parce que il faut essayer de
très précis sur les aspects techniques
et et factuels.
Est-ce que vous avez étudié euh au
autour des terrars des investissements
du genre on vous propose d'acheter des
terrares sur les marchés, on les stock
et
euh vous avez des vos terrars stockées
dans des bidons et euh quand vous voulez
les vendre, vous vendez vos terrars.
Vous avez étudié ce type de placement
financier ?
Alors moi je l'ai pas étudié. En
revanche, j'en ai entendu parler et donc
effectivement je je vois un peu de ce
qu'il s'agit. C'est-à-dire, vous avez
des gens qui viennent d'ailleurs, je
reçois des publicités qui viennent vous
dire investissez dans les terres rares
parce que si vous mettez quelques euros,
vu la l'importance de ce marché, le fait
que les courses seront à la hausse nous
promettent-il, et bien vous allez
récupérer 10 20 30 40 50 fois votre mise
de main. Euh et nous on stock ces terres
rares ou ces métaux rares en général en
physique. On les stock quelque part, ils
sont
souvent près d'un port. hein, et ça peut
se trouver près d'Amsterdam par exemple
et vous avez la garantie qu'il y a un il
y a il y a du physique derrière ce dont
on parle. Euh le vrai problème de ce
type d'offre, c'est que le cours de ces
métaux est extrême peut être extrêmement
variable. C'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
avoir des hausses extraordinaires de
coûts de des cours euh parce que à un
moment il y a une forte demande pour tel
métal par rapport à telle technologie,
mais demain ça s'effondre et donc vous
avez des variations de marché qui sont
très fortes. Donc certes, vous allez
récupérer 20 fois votre mise euh sur un
un coût, mais ça veut dire que quel vous
allez perdre 20 fois votre mise à un
moment ou un autre parce que les marchés
sont extrêmement variables. Et puis vous
avez un autre sujet autour de ça aussi
qui est que ce sont souvent les marchés
des météorars, des marchés opaques,
confidentiels et vous ne savez pas en
fait en réalité euh qui achète et à quel
prix parce que vous n'avez même pas les
prix. Et souvent vous apprenez que un
État qui tient ses métaux comme la Chine
manipule, il y a des forts soupçtions de
manipulation des prix par la Chine à la
baisse, pas à la hausse. Parce que la
Chine manipule les prix à la baisse.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle a intérêt à ce
que plus personne d'autre qu'elle
n'aille ouvrir pardon. C'est ça permet
de de rendre les gens dépendants.
Ça pas nous ça permet de nous rendre
dépendant des terreurs pas chers. Si le
dealer du bas de la rue vend sa cocaïne
deux fois moins cher, benouium
ou son opium connait bien
ou son craque deux fois moins cher. Et
bien en réalité ça peut être elle peut
être assurée qu'il va avoir l'entièreté
du du business. Donc c'est ça que fait
la Chine en fait. Elle vend son opium
des technologies vertes, des
technologies numériques beaucoup moins
cher parce que moi français avide
d'ouvrir une mine de terre rare pour
aller contourner le monopole chinois,
bah si je ne rentabilise pas ma mine à
courte échéance, je la ferme. Et donc la
Chine baisse les prix volontairement. En
tout cas, c'est un fort soupçon qui pèse
sur elle de sorte que et bien on ne
puisse pas ouvrir de mines alternatives.
La Chine ne pense pas en capitaliste sur
ce sujet-là. Et donc je reviens à notre
histoire de placement. Pourquoi faire un
placement dans les terres rares en
espérant récupérer 30 fois la mise si
par ailleurs vous apprenez qu'il y a des
manipulations de cours organisé par un
état qui tient cette production là et
qui manipule les prix à la baisse. Donc
c'est compliqué ces placements.
Ça a jamais été prouvé. Ça a été prouvé.
C'est la manipulation des cours. Alors
ça a pas complètement été prouvé parce
qu'effectivement il y a des débats mais
quand vous interrogez les éminents
spécialistes des terrares qui font un
peu le tour de des conférences à des
noms De Kings Nors, Christopherstone
Patrice Chrisman, Jack Lifton, une
majorité de ces experts vous disent
"Oui, il y a une il y a une manipulation
à la baisse par la Chine qui de fait
conserve le monopole ou un quasi
monopole sur ces matières premières
parce que les concurrents occidentaux ne
rentrent pas sur ce marché faute de
pouvoir avoir un business model
cohérent.
Je vais vous poser une question très
brute. Vous y croyez à la transition
écologique ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
Mais la transition écologique c'est un
leur, c'est une mystification,
c'est une transition technique, c'est
une transition industrielle, c'est une
transition des champs de pétrole vers
les mines de métau. Mais c'est pas une
transition écologique.
C'est une transition. C'est c'est le
passage d'un extractivisme à un autre
extractivisme. On est en train de
remplacer toute chose égale par ailleurs
parce que on va encore beaucoup dépendre
du pétrole et du charbon pour les
prochaines décennies hein. Dans nos mix
énergétiques comme on dit, la part du
pétrole et du charbon va rester
excessivement importante. Mais la part
de ce qu'on appelle les les énergies
vertes dans nos mix électriques
électriques va devenir plus importante
également. Et donc ce passage progressif
vers un âge plus sobre parce queon parle
de technologie verte va en fait nous
conduire à extraire toujours davantage
de matière davantage de matière minérale
davantage de fer, davantage d'acier,
davantage de cuivre davantage
d'aluminium et de zinc qui sont des
métaux abondants mais qui sont
nécessaires pour les technologies vertes
et davantage de tous ces petits métaux
rares, critiques, stratégiques comme les
terres rares, le galium, l'indium.
l'antimoine, le cobalt, le tental, le
tinste qui sont également pour la
plupart d'entre eux nécessaires pour
toutes ces technologie là. Et donc en
fait, on va essayer de régler un
problème autour de l'extraction du
pétrole et des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et de fait ça va peut-être
émettre un peu moins de CO2 de passer
dans l'âge du verre mais en même temps
ça va générer plus de pollution au
niveau minier avec pollution des eaux,
pollution des sols et cetera et cetera.
Donc on n'est pas en train de régler le
problème, on est en train de le déplacer
et on le déplace d'une économie à
l'autre. On le déplace d'une zone euh de
production pétrolière comme le
Moyen-Orient vers d'autres zones de
production de matière première comme la
Chine ou comme le Congo RDC pour le
cobalt ou comme les pays d'Amérique pour
le lithium ou le cuivre. Et donc en fait
le problème on ne le règle pas, on le
déplace. Et donc je ne crois pas une
demiseonde à ce mythe d'une transition
qui serait écologique. Ça ça va être une
transition énergétique parce
qu'effectivement dans la façon dont on
va avoir enfin notre nos sources
d'énergie vont être différentes. Elles
vont être différentes.
Ellux mixé.
Elles vont être mieux mixées.
Exactement. Et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
parler de transition énergétique et
d'addition énergétique. On va
additionner de nouvelles sources
d'énergie et de nouvelles façons de
produire de l'électricité à la façon
qu'on a eu jusque maintenant de produire
de l'électricité. Mais pour autant, ce
n'est pas une transition écologique et
ça va certes à mon avis permettre de
limiter un peu l'impact enfin les
émissions de CO2 parce que nos voitures
on l'ont moins avec du pétrole, mais ça
va générer d'autres problèmes avec
lesquels on va se retrouver 30 ans dans
10 20 30 ans avec ces immenses problèmes
sur les bras et on se dira maintenant
comment on fait dans ce nouvel âge vert
qui a généré autant de nouveaux
problèmes écologiques que ceux qu'il
avait résolu en essayant de fermer tant
bien que faire se peut la parenthèse de
l'âge thermoindustriel. Donc quand vous
avez Emmanuel Macron qui dit voilà, je
veux plus d'éolienne en France, quand
vous avez un ministre de l'écologie qui
a fond pour la la transition verte, la
transition écologique,
se battre contre la fatalité climatique
avec les yeux mouillés, les des très
mollos, des des des choses dans la dans
la voie. Excusez-moi, j'ai mon caméraman
qui faisait bouger sa caméra un peu
vite.
Quand vous les entendez parler comme ça
devant le micro, devant les caméras,
volontaire,
ça vous fait quoi en tant que
journaliste ? Celui qui a enquêté, qui a
été sur le terrain, qui a vu toute la
crasse que ça a généré ? Alors, quand on
est sur le terrain, on voit des choses
qui sont miroir inversé de ce qui se
raconte quand on n'est pas sur le
terrain.
Voilà. Et il faut aller sur le terrain
de même que tout un chacun est d'accord
pour dire que quand il rentre de voyage,
ça lui apporté une bouffée d'air et ça
lui a permis de revenir avec des idées
fraîches. Et ben moi, c'est mon métier
de revenir avec des idées fraîches et
des idées neuves. Et le terrain raconte
une autre histoire que l'histoire que je
entends lorsque je regarde une publicité
à la télévision pour la dernière voiture
électrique et lorsque je peux écouter
certains discours politiques. Et donc il
faut toujours revenir à ce terrainlà
parce que le terrain ne m pas et je
tiens vraiment à ça. Et donc on peut
discuter de plein de choses sur ces
questions-là parce que je sais que ça ça
crée ça ça génère un vrai débat.
Norement le terrain ne m pas. Voilà. Euh
qu'est-ce que ça me génère pareil ? Je
vous ai coupé.
Qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça me
Alors donc voilà. Ensuite euh j'ai
l'impression quand on parle de
transition qu'on transition énergétique.
Moi transition énergétique je suis pour.
Je veux dire on a tous envie de
transition. On est tous d'accord pour
dire
OK super plus de pétrole plus de
charbon. Génial. Bon, comme vous avez
compris, ça va être très long et ça va
être un un des des plus de mix et pas
forcément euh euh plus de pétrole versus
100 % d'énergie renouvelable. Euh donc
moi je suis pour simplement, j'ai
l'impression quand on en parle qu'on
comprend mal euh voir qu'on ne sait pas
du tout euh
les considérables enjeux que cela est en
train de charier. C'est-à-dire que dire
je fais ma transition énergétique, ça ça
implique une consommation, un appel
accru à des ressources minières comme
les métaux et comme les météorares dans
des proportions absolument
extraordinaires. Ça implique d'avoir
tout un système de production d'énergie
d'électricité pour nourrir cette machine
minière. Ça implique de nouvelles route
commerciale, y compris en physique pour
pouvoir être capable d'acheminer ces
minerais. Ça implique de l'eau. Ça
implique d'avoir de l'eau pour produire
trans pour se transformer une minera. On
va la on va on va la chercher où l'eau ?
Je prends un exemple. Euh mon
corréalisateur Jean-Louis Perez pour ce
film qu'on est en train de réaliser
était au Chili et on a voulu voir ce
qu'il y avait derrière un kilo de Chili
qui sort de la mine de Shokikamata qui
est la plus grande mine à ciel ouvert
des cuives de la planète. On l'a survolé
au drone.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette mine
? Bon derrière un kilo de de cuivre qui
va sortir de là. D'abord le cuivre il
sort pas raffiné, il sort à l'état brut.
Donc il va falloir le transformer ce
miner en métal. Mais pour le transformer
en métal, il faut de l'eau. Et l'eau, on
est dans le désert d'Acama. Donc il y a
pas beaucoup d'eau là-bas. Il y a des
eaux nul pas plus depuis 500 ans. Donc
on pompe un peu dans les nafréatiques et
puis à un moment on peut plus continuer
à pomper dans les fréatiques. Et
l'industrie minière chilienne dit on va
chercher de l'eau dans les dans l'océan.
Et donc on achemine l'eau de l'océan
Pacifique via des pipes. Donc il faut
construire des pipes pour que l'eau
arrive jusque dans la zone d'extraction
en de raffinage. L'eau, elle arrive pas
salée ou elle arrive pas complètement
salée. Il faut pour une partie d'entre
elles de cette eau, il faut la
désaliniser. Donc il faut qu'on soit une
centrale de désalinisation. Mais la
centrale de désalinisation, elle tourne
pas avec des pédales, il faut de
l'électricité et donc il faut une
centrale électrique. Et la centrale
électrique, elle tourne au charbon. 40 %
du mix électrique ou énergétique, j'ai
un doute, mais je crois que c'est du mix
électrique au Chili, c'est le charbon.
Et le charbon, il vient d'où ? vient de
Colombie et de Nouvelle-Zélande. Donc
c'est ça qu'on est en train de mettre en
place lorsqu'on parle d'aller chercher
du cuivre qui est nécessaire pour des
éoliennes et je vous rappelle que pour
certaines éoliennes, il faut 16 tonnes
de cuivre parce qu'il faut les raccorder
au réseau électrique. Donc il y a un
appel accru à ces ressources là et je
crois pas qu'aujourd'hui quand on parle
de transition énergétique on comprenne
tout ça. On n'a pas mis les chiffres sur
tout ça. On ne connaît pas les ACV, les
analyses de cycle de vie. On n' pas fait
des inventaires de cycle de vie. On ne
connaît pas le sac à dos écologique
comme on dit de c de ces technologies
là. c'est-à-dire toutes les ressources
qui ont été directement et indirectement
mobilisées pour arriver à ce produit
fini. Et on ne maîtrise pas bien
évidemment tout ce que ça implique en
terme de impact écologique direct et
indirect et l'eau par exemple qu'il faut
bien aller chercher quelque part et qui
est impliqué dans ce dans ce dans ce
dans ce processus minier là. Donc
aujourd'hui, je crois qu'il y a un
besoin de retour à des chiffres qui
permettent peut-être de parler de cette
transition en lui enlevant les mots
propres et les mots verts et les mots
responsables et les mots solidaires et
tous ces mots-là qui sont du bullshit.
Voilà, c'est avec vous que je le dis
parce que sinon je ne le dis pas
d'habitude quand je suis interrogé dans
des médias mais c'est vraiment les mots
qui qui sont évidemment ceux qui me
viennent les premières à l'esprit
lorsqu'on parle de ces technologies. Et
puis il y a des enjeux géopolitiques et
économiques derrière parce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que
avant de créer la de traiter les gens
parce que le politique ne comprend pas
ça non plus.
Moi je vais vous dire je vais je vais
essayer de raisonner en politique donc
je vais je vais m'envoie je vais
m'enlever la moitié de mon cerveau.
Créer des pipes, des canalisations pour
acheminer l'eau de mer des saliniser,
créer des petites C'est vachement bien.
On va créer de l'emploi. Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi vous raller
la
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Ouais,
bien sûr. La transition énergétique
c'est très chumpé rien. C'est
la destruction créatrice, c'est ça.
C'est la destruction créatrice. C'est on
va détruire des emplois dans l'âge de
l'âge ta industriel, dans le pétrole,
dans le charbon et ils vont être
remplacés par des emplois du monde vert.
Et donc tous ces emplois qui se qui se
qui se détruisent d'un côté, c'est des
emplois retrouvés de l'autre. Mais vous
savez, le problème c'est ces emploisl
ils vont être recréés. Mais à qui
vont-ils profiter ? Est-ce qu'ils vont
ça va être des emplois français qui vont
rester en France ou des emplois
européens qui vont rester en Europe ?
Est-ce que ça va être des petits enfants
en République démocratique du Congo qui
vont aller faire des trous ? Alors, il
il y a ce sujet de la question de savoir
dans quelles conditions on extrait du
cobalt dans les mines de République
démocratique du Congo et puis tous ces
emplois verts à haute valeur ajoutée,
c'est des emplois que l'orgent beaucoup
de pays qui profitent de cette nouvelle
donne énergétique qui est la transition
énergétique pour espérer sauter une
étape et en fait être capable de tirer
le meilleure partie de cette nouvelle
donne énergétique en tirant pour
eux-même le meilleur bénéfice de ces
emplois verts. Rappelez-vous quand même
que on a vécu un basculement des
énergies mondes au début du 20e siècle
lorsqu'on a basculé du charbon au
pétrole. Ce saut technologique,
ce saut technologique là qui était un
saut énergétique puisqu'on est passé de
la machine à vapeur au moteur à au
moteur à essence. Et bien ça euh alors
il y a plein de d'explications qui
permettent d'ex il y a toujours des
multiples critères à la perte
d'influence de du Royaume-Uni et la
montée en puissance des États-Unis à
cette époque mais il n'empêche qu'une
partie des événements de ce basculement
des économies mondes du Royaume-Uni vers
les États-Unis s'explique aussi par ce
changement d'ordre énergétique le
Royaume-Uni avait le charbon chez lui et
il tirait le meilleure partie des
technologies qui utilisaient le charbon
la machine à vapeur par exemple et la
tisseuse mécanique Le moment où on passe
à l'ordre à un système énergétique
dépendant, enfin qui dépend davantage du
pétrole, c'est tout béf pour les
Américains qui vont par ailleurs
sécuriser les routes du pétrole avec
l'Arabie Saoudite ou aller chercher du
pétrole. Enfin, ça viendra plus tard. Ça
viendra avec le pack du Quinsi dans les
années 40. Mais avant, les États-Unis
ont ce pétrole chez eux, notamment au
Texas. Et c'est ainsi qu' développent
les technologies qui se servent de ce
pétrole. Et c'est ainsi qu'arrive la
foreté en 1908 à D3 à Piquet. Et ben là,
on passe dans un nouvel ordre
énergétique puisqu'on va passer de la à
l'après-pétrole et donc c'est un nouveau
basculement des des économies mondes qui
arrivent mais cette fois-ci avantage à
l'avantage de la Chine parce que la
Chine a les matières premières, elle les
a sécurisé en tout cas pour pour ce qui
est des métaux rares. Elle a pas tous
les métaux, elle doit importer
énormément de métaux. Mais ces métaux
là, les plus stratégiques d'entre eux,
elle les a ou elle les a sécurisé chez
les Boliviens ou chez les Congolais
quand elle ne l'a pas. Et puis elle a la
maîtrise des technologies qui utilisent
ces métaux. Et donc en fait on bascule
dans un monde où c'est la Chine qui va
être capable de fabriquer cette
technologie verte. Et c'est ce qu'elle
fait. Elle fabrique la majorité des
panneaux solaires. Elle fabrique la
majorité des batteries de voitures
électriques. Aujourd'hui, elle va
fabriquer demain la majorité des
voitures électriques et demain nous
achèterons des voitures électriques
chinoises. Et donc toute cette idée
d'emploi verte à laquelle j'ai envie de
croire, faut regarder la réalité. tous
les emplois industriels du panneau du
secteur photovoltaïque,
ils ont été détruits en Europe quasiment
tous. Ils ont tous été recréés en Chine.
Et c'est ce qui peut se passer pour le
secteur de l'automobile et le secteur
des éoliennes. Donc attention à c à ce
basculement là qui consisterait à
remplacer certes des emplois par
d'autres mais pas dans la même zone du
monde ailleurs vers l'Asie. Et ça c'est
un vrai sujet pour les occidentaux qui
tiennent quand même à la croissance
verte.
Je je pose une question internet. Est-ce
que votre propre perspective, votre
sagesse a évolué au cours du temps face
aux réalités contraires au propagande
nationale ? Comment éclairer nos
décideurs ?
Waouh ! Est-ce que ma propre
perspective, est-ce que ma propre
sagesse euh d'abord, je pense que elle a
évolué ? Oui, parce que je veux dire, on
part tous du discours le plus facilement
accessible, c'est-à-dire la télévision
le plus facilement
digérable, c'est-à-dire un prête à
penser sur ces questions-là, y compris
le prête à penser politique sur ces
enjeux-là. Et donc il faut du temps pour
s'intéresser à aux aspects souterrains,
au sens le plus littéral du terme de ces
enjeux-là. Aller voir au-delà, voir en
dessous au sens le plus littéral du
terme. Euh enquêter, moi c'est la guerre
des métores, c'est 6 ans 6 ans, enfin
c'est j'ai pas fait que ça pendant 6
ans, mais c'est 6 ans d'enquête dans une
douzaine de pays pour à un moment
essayer d'avoir un de de de de de de me
de reconstruire un discours cohérent qui
soit en fait le miroir inversé du
discours officiel.
Et euh et donc 6 ans plus tard et 2 ans
après la publication de ce livre qui a
été publié en janvier de 2018, après
avoir rencontré tous les gens qui
travaillent dans ce secteurlà, les avoir
revu dans des conférences et cetera, bah
j'ai une vision beaucoup plus fine de
ces enjeuxl et donc peut-être que j'ai
acquis disons une capacité ou j'espère à
à à analyser tout ce discours là avec
beaucoup plus de de méfiance, beaucoup
plus d'esprit critique que ce que ça
pouvait être avant.
Euh d'une manière générale, dès qu'il y
a un enjeu industriel dans quelque
chose, un enjeu économique sur un sujet,
il faut se méfier. Enfin, je veux dire,
j'ai rien contre l'industriel. Il fait
son travail, il crée aussi des emplois
mais il fait il crée de la croissance.
Mais il faut faire extrêmement attention
à recouper ses sources. C'est le job
premier de journaliste de sortir de ces
discours officiels et d'aller recouper
avec un certain nombre de sources
transversales pour sortir de ces
discours convenus. C'est ce qui apporte
un peu de vérité au sujet qu'on qu'on
étudie.
Vous vous parlez de croissance.
Ouais.
Euh est-ce que vous y croyez à cette
croissance advitamernam ? Est-ce que
vous pensez que la décroissance est
jouable ? Est-ce queon va pouvoir
rentrer dans en décroissance sans
déstabiliser trop les marchés financiers
?
Est-ce que l'Union européenne fait des
anticipations de consommation de ces
métaux rares ? Quelle consommation va
pour les 25 prochaines années, la
génération qui va utiliser ce téléphone
portable pour regarder des vidéos de
chat, elle va consommer autant de métau
rar que depuis les 2000 dernières
années. Euh
est-ce que le cette sacre sainte
croissance,
est-ce que c'est pas du bouchite aussi ?
Est-ce que la la la période d'abondance
qu'on a connu depuis les 100 dernières
années est pas totalement révolue ? et
on va rentrer dans une ère où où la la
l'abondance est terminée.
Alors euh d'abord euh si on regarde
quelques chiffres à commencer par ceux
de l'OCDE, nous allons consommer d'ici
2060, c'est une étude de 2018 de l'OCDE,
entre 2011 et 2060, l'humanité va
consommer deux fois plus de matière
première
que depuis
non en fait elle sa consommation de
matière première en 2060 sera deux fois
supérieure à annuelle sera supérieure à
celle de 2011. Donc ça veut dire que
nous sommes dans un âge d'extraction
toujours plus forte de matière première
avec tous les enjeux sous-jacents de
ressources qu'il faut aller chercher
pour fabriquer la ressource pour
fabriquer la ressource comme ce que j'ai
expliqué au Chili. Si on regarde plus
précisément les marchés du lithium, du
cobalt, du Tsten, du Vanadium et cetera
qui sont des métaux très précis, très
spéciaux, très stratégiques avec des
besoins très particuliers pour nos
nouvelles technologies, c'est pas x 2,
c'est x 5 x 9 x 15 x 44 pour le cuivre
entre 2013 et 2035 x 180 pour le lithium
entre 2013 et 2035. C'est des chiffres
de l'Agence minérale allemande. Donc
effectivement, on n'est pas sur quelque
chose qui ressemble à de la décroissance
quand on regarde ces chiffres
d'extraction présent et futur parce que
on revient à ce sujet
l'accélération technologique est
consommatrice de ces matières premières.
Et on peut toujours essayer d'aller en
recycler quelques-uns et de faire la
substitution et de dire on va découpler.
La réalité c'est que on tout va
exploser. Tout va exploser. Alors
ensuite est-ce qu'on peut continuer
comme ça ? Ma réaction de citoyen quand
je regarde ces chiffres c'est de dire
non. Bah je veux dire on peut pas
continuer comme ça. Et évidemment qu'à
un moment
je veux dire les écosystèmes,
tout cela ne peut pas soutenir de tel de
tel de tel uneeun telle accélération
extractive. Vous me posez une question
qui est extrêmement délicate et je dois
vous dire qu'elle me met dans la gêne et
que j'ai du mal à y répondre qui est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce qu'on fait
de la décroissance ? Et je suis
extrêmement malaise ces questions et je
vous avoue que je suis en réflexion par
rapport à ces sujets-là et que j'ai pas
encore tranché parce que il y a quelque
chose qui est pour moi invendable, c'est
la croissance à tout craintam et ternam.
Ça n'a pas de sens et il y a quelque
chose qui me paraît tout aussi
invendable, c'est la décroissance.
Parce que je veux dire à un moment
pardon mais on a vécu la crise des
gilets jaunes au plus fort de la crise
des gilets jaunes décembre 2018 et c'est
pas fini. Euh, il a fallu que le
président Macron fasse une annonce. Il a
fait des annonces et il a fait une
annonce forte. Il a dit
"Venez me chercher." Non,
je vais comment ?
Il a pas dit "Venez me chercher."
Il a dit "On va euh", il a peut-être dit
ça mais il a dit "On va augmenter le
SMIC de 100 €." Donc c'est de la
croissance.
Il a pas dit "On va baisser le SMIC de
100 €." Il a pas dit "Je vous ai
compris, je vais baisser le SMIC de 100
€." Si il avait dit ça, où est-ce qu'on
serait aujourd'hui ? Est-ce qu'il y aura
encore de une 5è République en France ?
Donc personne n'est prêt à la
croissance. Alors oui, c'est le riche
qui va payer.
Personne n'est prêt à la décroissance.
Excusez-moi. Personne n'est prêt à la
décroissance. Donc oui, le riche va
payer. Bien évidemment, c'est lui qui va
compenser ça, mais moment ce discours
n'est plus tenonnable. La décroissance,
c'est pour tout le monde. Voilà. Et donc
je ne crois pas aujourd'hui que qui que
ce soit en France soit vraiment prêt, à
part bien évidemment quelques
exceptions, mais ça reste très marginal
à quelque chose qui soit de l'ordre de
la décroissance systémique. Et donc je
ne vois pas un système aujourd'hui qui
soit capable politiquement parlant le
tenir sur cette idée de décroissance de
consommation énergétique, de notre
consommation de bien en général et
cetera et cetera. nos nos systèmes ne
sont pas faits comme ça. Et et donc je
je m'inquiète de cette de cette solution
qui euh comporte sa part de radicalité,
donc de vérité mais de radicalité, mais
qui me paraît pas euh cohérente et et
compatible avec la stabilisation, la
stabilité de nos systèmes politiques
tels que nous les connaissons
aujourd'hui en Occident et en
particulier en France. Et donc entre
l'extrême de la croissance sans
s'arrêter avec les chiffres que je vous
ai dit et l'extrême de la décroissance,
je je je me pose la question qu'est-ce
qu'on fait entre les deux ? Alors
post-croissance, les Belges sont dessus,
je sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire. On
découpe, on va continuer à croître mais
en baissant notre consommation de
matière première. Mais ce découplage,
c'est pas évident qu'on y arrive. Est-ce
qu'il faut faire de la décroissance
sélective et de la croissance sélective
? Je sais pas s'il faut la décroissance,
mais il faut de la décroissance. Ça veut
dire que j'ai intérêt à pousser pour que
le secteur minier décroisse mais qu'en
même temps le secteur du recyclage
croiss
jamais je recycle mieux plus de métaux
et ben du coup c'est moins de métaux à
aller chercher à la mine et donc quelque
part la baisse de l'activité d'un
secteur peut être compensée par la
hausse de l'activité d'un autre secteur
ça reste très choup rien. J'ai intérêt à
ce que le vendeur de téléphones portable
périclite mais que le loueur de
téléphones portables usagers qui vont du
coup rester le plus longtemps possible
dans les boucles de consommation,
celui-ci au contraire connaisse son un
un de beau et de beaux jours devant lui.
Donc je je j'espère imaginer que on peut
trouver un équilibre qui ne soit pas
dans ces deux extrêmes là. J'en suis là.
Euh je
je je tâonne et pour autant encore une
fois ma première réflexion lors que je
reviens du terrain, que je vois les
impacts écologiques, que je vois les
incohérences de du capitalisme vert et
quand je vois les chiffres de
production, bien évidemment c'est de me
dire ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
et à un moment qu'on le veuille ou pas
on va bien devoir changer parce qu'on
aura pas forcément le choix
changer Pourquoi alors ?
Ah ça je sais pas.
Pas d'idée.
Changer pourquoi ? Avons poser une belle
question.
Ben en fait ça nous amène à
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se réinvente
un imaginaire. Euh il faut qu'on
réinvente notre la façon d'imaginer le
futur aujourd'hui. Imaginer le futur si
tentez que dans les discours de de ceux
et celles qui porte notre horizon d'un
point de vue politique, on entend des
choses
à 5 10 15 ans parce que moi je pas
beaucoup d'horizon politique
aujourd'hui. Mais en tout cas, je je
trouve que le politique a du mal à nous
emmener vraiment à moyen terme. Il y a
que les Chinois qui pensent à long
terme.
Le discours aujourd'hui c'est de dire
plus de prospérité, plus de croissance,
moins de chômage, des retraites mieux
valorisées et cetera et cetera. Mais si
pour moi, je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat,
la France est en marche et on est tous
sauvés.
Si si on en reste là, effectivement, on
changera pour on ne changera pas. Euh si
on veut changer pour alors changer
pourquoi ? Ça implique de réinventer
complètement et de réimaginer un
discours qui remettent le bien-être, qui
remettent la croissance ailleurs que
dans cette croissance strictement
chiffrée et et comptable. Et donc c'est
peut-être la croissance du bien-être
compte tenu de notre exposition plus
plus quotidienne à la nature, de notre
exposition moindre à à certaines
pollutions générées par l'extractivisme
ou bien par le le le le le
les industries. C'est bien évidemment
peut-être la croissance mais je dis des
pardon mais je dis des choses qui sont
complètement évidentes. la croissance
d'une qualité de vie à défaut d'une
croissance de la de la de la quantité de
vie de quantité de consommation. Sachez
quand même que il y a des gens qui sont
très au fait de ça, c'est les Chinois.
Et en fait, contrairement à ce qu'on
pense, la Chine est en fait peut-être
même en avance par rapport à nous sur
ces sujets-là parce que c'est le pays
qui se prend qui à la fois vit, je veux
dire un qui aujourd'hui est en pleine
croissance et dont la croissance du
pouvoir d'achat est colossale chaque
année. Croissance, ils ralentissent un
peu là, leurs chiffres de croissance
sont bidouillés.
Ils sont bidouillés. Donc ils étaient à
10, après ils sont passés à 6,
maintenant ils seraient peut-être à 4 et
encore il faut regarder. Mais bon, je
aujourd'hui si on compare la Chine
d'aujourd'hui à la Chine d' ans il
suffit d'aller en Chine de voir la
taille des la hauteur des tours de
Shangï pour comprendre que il y a eu de
la croissance et donc les Chinois
profitent de ça et en même temps ce sont
les premiers à se prendre l'effet
boomerang écologique de cette croissance
et sociale
parce que c'est l'usine du monde donc
parce que ce sont eux qui produisent
pour le reste du monde et pour
eux-mêmes. Donc il subissent les
contre-coups écologiques, y compris les
machines enfin les centrales à charbon
qui tournent à plein régime et donc les
conséquences sociales parce que les
Chinois, ils sont pas du tout contents
de vivre pendant 6 mois de l'année avec
une chape nuage à base de dioxyde de
carbone stocké, coincé, bloqué au-dessus
de leur ville. J'étais à Shengdou, c'est
la capitale du Sichuan il y a quelques
années pour un reportage pour le monde
diplomatique et je me rappelle d'une
étudiante de 23 ans.
Comment on leur passe le bonjour ?
et ben une étudiante de 23 ans qui me
disait euh pendant 6 mois on voit pas le
soleil pendant les 6 mois d'hiver parce
que les usines à charbon tournent à
plein régime et bien en fait on ne voit
pas le soleil le temps que le on arrête
de se chauffer au charbon et quand
l'hiver cesse et quand arrive le
printemps et qu'on cesse de se chauffer
alors les usines s'éteignent et à ce
moment-là le soleil réapparaît. Et me
dit-elle "On a vu le soleil apparaître,
on l'avait pas eu depuis 6 mois. Les
gens ont sorti leur téléphone portable
et ont photographié le soleil. Donc ça
devient social. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de manifestations en Chine pas
pour de la quantité de vie et de pouvoir
d'achat mais pour de la qualité de vie.
Et c'est là que vous avez 30 à 50000
manifestations sont des chiffres non
officiels en Chine pour des raisons
environnementales et que ça crée des
troubles personnes
avec plus de 1000 personnes. avec plus
de 1000 personnes et ça crée des
troubles et ça crée des troubles sociaux
qui euh commence à inquiéter enfin
depuis plusieurs années le parti
communiste chinois qui se dit que il va
peut-être falloir euh alors resserrer
les vis évidemment plus de surveillance
et cetera, mais qui se dit aussi il va
peut-être falloir que et bien on éteigne
les usines à charbon, qu'on les ferme du
jour au lendemain, qu'on ferme des mines
qui sont juste des catastrophes
environnementales, qu'on empêche à je ne
sais quelle usine de teinture de de
vêtements de rejeter directement ses eux
usées dans le fleuve du coin et puis
vous avez des photos de fleuves avec des
eaux rouges ou bleu ou oranges. Mais ça
ça veut dire moins de croissance. Et
donc le PC aujourd'hui fait ce choix
d'une moindre croissance pourvu qu'il y
ait plus de qualité de vie parce que de
toute façon ça va pas tenir. La
légitimité du PCC est remise en cause
s'ils ne font pas ça.
Donc là là il y a une question qui est
en train de revenir souvent sur la sur
notre IRC. Les colabsolques, vous en
pensez quoi ?
Alors euh je suis mal à l'aise. Je suis
mal à l'aise.
Ils sont très sympas hein.
Comment
ils sont très sympas.
Ils sont très sympas. J'ai l'occasion de
rencontrer Pabo Servigne que je
à qui je passe le bonjour qui est fort
sympathique. Je suis mal à l'aise avec
les clapsologues parce que
euh on vit des effondrements. C'est une
évidence. Il suffit de regarder le
nombre d'insectes ou la diversité la
biodiversité aujourd'hui par rapport il
y a 30 ou 40 ans pour dire il y a un
effondrement. C'est c'est un constat.
Il y a il y a des effondrements. Il y a
un type d'effondrement. Dire c'est
l'effondrement au sens de l'effondrement
général. Je suis pas à l'aise avec cette
cette thèse là. Non pas que je n'ai pas
conçu connaissance de ces thèses, hein.
Je je les connais parfaitement. J'en
connais aussi les les les
démonstrations. Mais si vous voulez, je
autant je constate que on a tendance à
aggraver les problèmes plutôt qu'à les
plutôt qu'à les régler. Autant euh de là
à dire à un moment il y a un peu comme
dans Barjavel euh c'était quoi ? C'était
pas la nuit des temps, c'était ravage.
Euh il y a un un maillon de toute cette
chaîne qui euh qui s'éteint et puis ou
qui vient à manquer puis en fait tout le
système s'effondre. Je suis je suis pas
à l'aise avec ces thèses là.
Permettez-moi de constater que la fin du
monde ça dure depuis la nuit des temps.
Je veux dire la fin du monde c'est
quelque chose qui est en nous. Alors, je
vais je vais parler comme un
collapsologue. Regardez les Mayas,
regardez les Romains. C'est des empires.
C'est ces empires qui sont gaffrés pour
des questions énergétique, qui sont
gaufré pour des questions climatiques.
Sont effondré. Donc, vous avez
parfaitement raison. Euh, depuis la
chute de Rome, il y a un livre sur
l'histoire de la chute de monde qui a
été l'histoire de la fin du monde qui a
été publiée en 2012 et qui euh
qui l'a fait ? Non
non, non, c'était un français et son nom
m'échappe. C'est dommage parce qu'il
faut vraiment le lire. et il a
comptabilisé que depuis la chute de Rome
en 476, on a annoncé la fin du monde 182
fois et euh voilà, on on vit peut-être
une forme de 183e annonce mais ce que je
veux dire, c'est que ça fait partie de
nos de nos ressorts intimes et de notre
résilience que de préparer cette fin du
monde, que de l'imaginer, que de se
préparer au pire pour imaginer, espérer,
changer, changer dans les faits et aller
vers l'après qui sera meilleur que la
fois précédente. Mais je suis mal à
l'aise avec cette idée de dire "Bon,
cette fois-ci, on a vraiment raison, ça
va vraiment s'arrêter." Je crois que
c'est histor l'histoire de la fin du
monde nous montre qu'on a toujours eu
besoin de s'attendre au pire pour
pouvoir changer au service de notre
résilience. Et donc en ce sens, je ne
crois pas à l'effondrement.
Donc vous croyez pas à l'effondrement.
Est-ce que vous connaissez en détail
leur thèse ? Oui, parce que j'ai lu euh
comment tout peut s'effondrer de Pablo
Servigne et euh Guillaume Chapelle et
Raphaël Stevens et j'ai lu également
comment tout va s'effondrer de "Il va me
revenir mais c'est chez mon éditeur qui
libère." Donc je connais leur thèse mais
on peut on peut discuter dans le détail
des thèses. Moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est cette démonstration de de
l'interconnexion en fait des systèmes
notamment énergétique, transport et
cetera. Et ça c'est quand même très
intéressant de de voir que cette
interconnexion en fait fragilise nos
systèmes et que la résilience ce serait
paradoxalement justement de se
déconnecter de se détendre. Système
on système overstretch en ce moment
c'est la la leur grande phrase c'est le
système hypertendu
et à la moindre surtension par effet de
mytho tous vôtre.
Tout à fait.
On met de côté de temps en temps, du
moins on fait on ferme cette parenthèse
colapsologique. La sécurisation
militaire et les déploiements
géostratégiques, les les projections
militaires des États européens pour
aller sécuriser les matières premières
énergétiques. Vous les avez étudié ?
Vous en avez vu, vous avez vu quelque
chose ? Bon, mis à part les Chinois qui
se projettent un peu partout,
la France fait des choses pour
Non, aujourd'hui il y a pas de il y a
pas de projection militaire.
Après, il faudrait rentrer dans la
question du Mali que j'ai pas bien
étudié. Alors sincèrement, je pour des
matières premières stratégiques comme
les métau stratégiques, je je parle de
ma lucarne parce que c'est ce que je
connais sincèrement, je vois pas. Je
vois pas. Alors après le Mali, c'est
encore une question et je je ne sais pas
mais aujourd'hui est-ce que l'Europe et
la France ont des projections euh
militaires sur ces enjeux de métau
rares, critiqu stratégique ? Non, on ne
se fait pas la guerre aujourd'hui. Et
d'ailleurs, vous savez qui me le dit,
c'est Alain Juillet. qui est dans le
livre, qui est interrogé euh qui je sais
bien est également passé par ici euh à
qui j'ai posé la question de savoir si
les services français s'étaient
intéressés à ces questions-là et
l'invier me répond les services français
sont des je cite quasiment vers bâtime
he j'ai oublié le le mot à mot ce qu'il
y a dans le livre mais dans mon livre
mais les services français sont à des
années lumières de ces sujets là donc
quant à vous dire si l'armée française y
est je pense qu'elle a plein de sujets
en tête
mais pas celui d'aller sécuriser du
Tental au fin fond de la République
démocratique du Congo ou d'aller
regarder qu'est-ce qu'on peut extraire
et sécuriser comme lithium. Donc je vois
pas d'enjeux militaire autour de ça et
aujourd'hui on se fait pas forcément la
guerre pour ces métaux rares.
Alors il y a on a une réflexion de notre
communauté sur internet qui nous dit euh
c'est qui nous nous dit ça. C'est il dit
Pablo Servigne pour ne citer que lui ne
parle pas de la fin du monde mais de la
fin d'un monde soit d'un effondrement
systémique de tivisation
thermoindustrielle. Ne pas saisir la
nuance, c'est ne pas connaître le sujet.
Ça dans les dents.
Euh et pourtant, je l'ai lu. Donc vous
voyez euh
l'effondrement est perçu par les gens
comme étant une forme de fin du monde.
Enfin, je veux dire, j'entends ce que
dit ce qui est enfin la façon c'est
exprimé et qualifié par Pablo Servigne,
mais je pense que quand vous parlez
d'effondrement aux gens, descendez dans
la rue pour leur poser la question, les
mots qui comprennent vont bien au-delà.
et je je moi je les reçois aussi comme
ça. Donc je je l'ai exprimé par rapport
à ma propre compréhension aussi de ces
enjeux-là et je pense que on perçoit
beaucoup l'effondrement comme étant un
âge de chaos qui euh dont on pourrait
difficilement se relever. Mais j'entends
ce que vous dites et pourtant je suis
lecteur du peuple servir.
Revenons à nos militaires. Donc ils sont
à des années lumières d'aller sécuriser
des nos approvisionnement. Euh nos
politiques sont euh un peu larguées avec
euh du bullshit word dans la bouche pour
prendre le contrôle de la dialectique,
rassurer tout le monde. Tout va bien se
passer. Les projections de consommation
sont là. On va toujours sur une
consommation exponentielle. Business à
Joel.
Business as jou.
C'est comme ça qu'on dit. Green Business
as dual.
Green Business as usual. Greta Tonberg,
dans tout ça, vous en pensez quoi ?
Euh Greta Tonberg
est indispensable.
Elle est indispensable pour accélérer
cette prise de conscience. Donc Greta
Grenberg dit la science, elle nous dit
elle nous met face à nos réalités de
consommateur, face aux conséquences
réelles de nos actes de consommation,
face à nos contradictions, face à notre
myopie, face à notre peut-être égoïsme
aussi. Et en ce sens, j'adhère
parfaitement à à ces à ces à l'alarme,
au cri d'alarme qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle
qu'elle pousse parce que elle est
indispensable pour accélérer une prise
de conscience qui doit être beaucoup
plus puissante, radicale, systémique que
notre transition gentillette non
écologique que nous essayons de de à
laquelle nous essayons vaguement de
croire aujourd'hui. Donc Katberg
est beaucoup plus radicale dans son
discours et elle nous elle nous met en
face d'une nécessaire radicalité de nos
actions qui est je crois absolument
nécessaire.
Euh, on prendra les questions internet
dans pas très longtemps. Est-ce que vous
avez suivi le fait que
certains GFA pas il y a Google qui se
fait attaquer, il y a je crois qu'il y a
d'autres d'autres d'autres gros grosses
multinationales qui se font attaquer
parce que il ils feraient travailler des
enfants
Oui. Oui.
Où ils se font attaqués dans le cobalt
enfin il feraiit. C'est pas eux qui les
font travailler.
C'est pas eux bien entendu. Euh mais de
fil en aiguille à la fin, c'est eux euh
qui qui vont se faire attaquer.
Euh vous voyez beaucoup de démarches de
la société civile dans ce sens-là.
Est-ce que il y a des groupes qui se
réveillent qui se mettent en collectif
pour dire là bon maintenant ça suffit.
Euh est-ce qu'il y a des industriels qui
se mettent avec ces groupes comme les
fairphone ou les choses comme ça pour
dire voilà maintenant c'est le
consommateur qui dicte sa loi et on
bouge. Vous avez suivi des choses comme
ça ? Oui. Euh le sujet du cobalt et plus
précisément de l'extraction du cobalt
dans des mines artisanales dans la
province du Katanga au Congo et
notamment par des enfants, c'est la
patate chaude. C'est-à-dire que le
moment où vous commencez à mon à mettre
des images sur cette réalité, ça charit
ses images chari avec elle une telle
violence
émotionnelle. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est
une telle puissance émotionnelle que
c'est l'un des sujets qui est le plus
porté par la société civile quand il
s'agit de parler des métaux que l'on
trouve dans nos technologies du
quotidien.
Est-ce qu'il faudrait mettre par exemple
sur les boîtes de téléphone portables
toutes neuves, toutes belles, toutes
bien designées par des sociétés, est-ce
qu'il faudrait mettre des photos comme
sur les paquets de clopes
euh des trucs comme ça ? Genre genre le
trou de la mine machin, le petit enfant
qui ne mange pas mais qui a les mains
dans la mine, genre le cancer du poumon
chez le chinois qui a trop respiré le
graphite ou des choses comme ça.
Euh alors c'est c'est très radical et
proposition très très provocatrice mais
après tout si on dit fumer tu voilà la
vie tue. Et après tout, effectivement
téléphoner, utiliser un téléphone
portable, ça a un impact sur la planète
et ça a un impact sur les conditions
sociales des gens qui travaillent dans
les mines qui permettent de fabriquer
des téléphones portables. Donc on serait
bien inspiré, nous consommateurs, de
d'avoir la sagesse de regarder la
réalité de l'extraction de ces métaux.
Bon euh donc je pense qu'il y a quelque
chose qu'on pourrait faire qui serait
facile à faire, c'est de parler de
l'intensité matérielle du téléphone. Je
m'explique. Quand vous achetez un billet
à la SNCF, il y a l'intensité carbone de
votre billet. C'est-à-dire vous avez
pris un train entre Paris et Lyon et ça
a généré tant de carbone. Donc vous avez
ce chiffre là. Pourquoi pas faire pareil
avec un téléphone portable ? Et pourquoi
pas dire votre téléphone portable qui
pèse 120 g ? Et bien pour le fabriquer,
il a fallu 70 kg, 100 kg, 120 kg de
matière. Et le ratio entre le poids du
produit fini et la matière qui a été
mobilisée en amont pour faire ce
produit, c'est 1 à 500, 1 à 1000. C'est
1000 fois plus jusqu'à 1000 fois plus de
matière en amont pour arriver au
produits finis. Et ça, je pense que ça
mériterait de l'écrire et d'avoir au dos
de nos téléphones littéralement et
pourquoi pas quelque part au moment où
on achète sa voiture cette ce ce
chiffre là, ce qu'on appelle le matériel
input, le M per j'ai oublié le
excusez-moi, j'ai j'ai un trou, mais ce
sac à dos écologique pour le dire
autrement qui en fait nous permet de
constater par un chiffre simple combien
il peut y avoir comme dégradation
environnementale derrière un téléphone,
derrière un produit fini tout bout tout
propre. Si je dis au moment d'acheter un
nouveau téléphone, bah oui, mais c'est
un trou de 70 kg ou de 100 kg dans le
sol pour te faire un nouveau téléphone,
peut-être que je peux réagir
différemment jusqu'à votre proposition
plus radicale qui après tout se peut se
tenir. Est-ce que les gens sont au
courant de ça ? La la je réponds à votre
question. La la la les ONG de plus en
plus mais il y en a pas beaucoup.
C'est-à-dire que bon aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt en fait une ONG en particulier,
c'est Amnesty Internation. Non, je crois
que c'est Human Rights Watch. Non, c'est
Human Right. Alors, Sherpa commence à
s'y intéresser. D'ailleurs, ils m'ont
contacté. Euh c'est Human Rights Watch
qui euh ou non, attendez, excusez-moi,
c'est Amnesty International qui a fait
un rapport en 2017 qui s'appelle
Recharge. Et ce rapport en fait le point
sur les conditions de travail dans les
mines avec des enfants au Congo et a été
capable de remonter le lien jusqu'au
produits finis et de cibler des dizaines
d'industriels de la voiture électrique,
des industriels, des téléphones
portables en disant "Mais c'est ce
cobalt là qui termine dans vos
batteries." Et ils ont interrogé tous
ces industriels qui ont répondu en
disant "On était pas au courant." Et euh
cette ONG a dit "Non mais si moi j'ai pu
faire ce travail en quelques semaines,
comment ne pouvez-vous pas le faire ?"
Et ça a eu l'effet d'un électrochoc
parce que notamment Renault s'est
retrouvé directement ciblé avec à
l'époque Carlos Gaun qui a dû répondre
de ces questions là devant des députés
dans le cadre d'une commission
d'enquête. Carlos Gon a dit "Attendez,
moi j'achète pas de cobalt, j'achète des
batteries." Oui, mais en fait tu achètes
du cobalt donc tu es censé être au
courant. Et donc euh les industriels ont
pris conscience du risque que ça
représente euh que d'aller chercher des
minerais dans des zones où les règles
les droits de l'homme ne sont pas
respectés. Et donc l'industriel, il est
obligé d'agir. Il agit pas par
conversion écologique ou par conviction
écologique. Il agit parce que ça va lui
côter de l'argent. ça va lui coûter de
l'argent de se retrouver à devoir
répondre de la presse à l'occasion d'une
campagne négative dans la presse et ça
risque de lui coûter aussi quelques
points à la bourse le lendemain. Et donc
l'industriel y commence à agir en terme
de sourcing éthique à mieux contrôler
l'origine des minerais parce que il veut
se protéger parce que il sait
qu'aujourd'hui ça devient un enjeu de
réputation fort et donc ça va lui coûter
de l'argent s'il ne prend pas cet enjeu
à bras le corps. Donc c'est les sujets
qui commencent à monter de là à vous
dire que c'est systémique. On est très
loin très loin de faire de cela une
politique systémique.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous voyez
d'autres sujet aborder avec nous ?
Euh je pense que parce que vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure d'aspect militaire
mais il y a tout un versant militaire
aussi de toutes ces matières premières
qui est ces matières premières servent
pour les technologies militaires, elles
servent pour les missiles intelligents,
elles servent pour les F35 par exemple.
Et il y a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui au
bout et ça servira dans les rafales. Il
y a un vrai sujet aux États-Unis qui est
en train de monter autour de ces
sujets-là. C'est-à-dire on a besoin de
ces matières premières rares. La Chine
tient une bonne partie de la production.
Nous sommes dépendants des
approvisionnements chinois et à
Washington en pleine guerre commerciale
face à la Chine, c'est pas le moment
d'avoir le président Sijinping qui se
pointe comme ça a été le cas en mai 2019
dans une usine de raffinage de terra
dans le Ganxi au sud de la Chine pour
faire comprendre que si jamais les
Américains continuent de les embêter sur
le volet du commerce international, les
Chinois peuvent réagir en cessant leurs
exportations de ces minerais. Je dis pas
que les Chinois le feront parce que
c'est un bouton rouge auquel à mon avis
ils ne toucheront pas, sur lequel ils
n'appuyeront pas. Mais ça pose une vraie
question de souveraineté nationale et de
souveraineté de sécurité nationale et le
sujet est en train de monter aux
États-Unis sous cet angle-là. Donc il y
a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui qui est
politisé par la Maison Blanche et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose que de
dire on peut pas continuer comme ça et
c'est pour ça que Trump au mieux de
l'été dit "J'achèterai bien le
Groenland". Ça paraît drôle mais en fait
quelque part il y a ces enjeux de
matière première. Et peut-être un
dernier point aussi que j'aimerais
évoquer, c'est que souvent euh j'ai pu
entendre dire "Mais euh vous nous
laissez en plan face à ces sujets-là,
vous nous avez expliqué que le verre
n'était pas vert, que finalement on
retombait dans des problèmes aussi
colossaux que les problèmes que cette
transition permettait de résoudre. On
fait quoi après ça ? Vous êtes un
une comment dirais-je ? Un faunet du
pétrole, du charbon.
C'est c'est c'est rien du tout. Euh je
suis trop content de me débarrasser du
pétrole, du charbon. Je ne veux plus
entendre parler et on est tous d'accord
pour dire que si le nucléaire peut
baisser dans les mixes énergétiques,
c'est bien. Mais donc pas le cas
d'ailleurs,
ce qui sera pas forcément le cas, mais
moi, je suis pour cette transition et
comprenez-moi, écologique et je préfère
à la rigueur plus d'éolienne
et et moins de centrale à charbon. Je
préfère plus de panneaux solaires et et
moins de central à pétrole. à choisir,
je prends je prends pour au moins une
raison, c'est parce que ça émet moins de
gaz à effet de serre. Ça va générer plus
de pollution notamment au niveau minier
parce qu'il va falloir besoin il va
fallir il y aura besoin de plus de
ressources minières pour fabriquer ces
technologies mais si ça consomme moins
de d'hydrocarbure et que ça génère moins
de CO2 dans l'atmosphère et que ça
permet de limiter l'impact du
réchauffement de 2°gr ou 1,5 degrés
d'ici 2100, moi je dis OK. Alors dans ce
cas-là, prononçant prenons ça, c'est un
moindre mal. Et donc je ne suis pas
contre cette transition. J'ai envie de
dire essayons de la faire mais aller
vers le verre avec des lunettes roses,
c'est un leur absolu. Et donc OK pour
faire cette transition mais comment
est-ce qu'on l'a fait ? Et je pense que
je terminerai à moins que vous ayez
d'autres questions en vous disant il y a
des choses à faire pour limiter les
effets pervers de cette transition et
peut-être que si on les met strictement
en œuvre, on va peut-être y arriver. Et
d'abord, il faut connaître la vérité
technologique, la vérité écologique
pardon des technologies. Le mot vérité
écologie des technologies, c'est un mot
de Corine Lepage que j'aime bien, la
vérité écologie des technologies.
C'est-à-dire que si jamais on a euh ces
informations chiffrées sur l'impact
matière des technologies, si on fait ce
qu'on appelle les scopes 1 2 3,
c'est-à-dire qu'on est capable euh de
calculer au niveau d'une entreprise ou
d'une administration euh ce que l'on
pollue euh de façon directe, l'énergie
qu'on utilise et ce que l'on pollue de
manière indirecte parce qu'il faut des
matières pour fabriquer des matières
pour fabriquer des matières pour
fabriquer mon produit fini. Alors, j'ai
une meilleure connaissance des
différents périmètres de pollution que
j'ai moi-même euh généré. Et la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015 oblige
aujourd'hui les acteurs de l'économie
française à faire ses calculs de scope 1
2 3. Donc ça ça va dans une bonne
direction. C'est
c'est pas la loi pacte, c'est ça ?
Non, c'est la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015. C'est une loi
passée par le précédent gouvernement.
Enfin, la loi Pact aussi du précédent
gouvernement, mais là c'est une loi qui
est de 2015, qui n'est pas la loi Pacte.
Mais donc là, il y a une évolution
intéressante qui est de dire mettons des
chiffres sur tout ça, améliorons notre
comptabilité et au moins face à ces
chiffres déjà comme dit Francis Bacon,
le savoir c'est le pouvoir et donc si je
sais, je peux mieux agir. Bon, mais ça
c'est une première chose qui est
indispensable. Ensuite, il va falloir
mieux sourcer l'origine de la matière,
mieux contrôler d'où elle vient et je
veux bien faire sa transition mais à la
condition que et bien on aille chercher
des minerais dans des conditions plus
éthiques et qu'on ne reproduise pas en
réalité des phénomènes de domination
culturelle de l'Occident sur le reste du
monde avec cette transition énergétique
comme on est en train de le faire
actuellement parce que après tout nous
allons chercher ces minerais chez les
plus pauvres. Il faut recycler
l'économie circulaire reste
indispensable. Je dis pas que c'est la
solution à tout hein. Euh on a beau
pouvoir recycler 100 % d'un minerai ou
d'un métal pardon, ça empêche pas de
devoir continuer à aller chercher de
nouveaux métaux à la mine euh parce que
notre consommation est plus forte. Mais
quand même, on est tous d'accord pour
dire que si jamais on se donne la peine
de mieux recycler tous ces métaux rares
qu'on recycle à moins de 1 %, le monde
se porterait pas plus mal. Et donc ça
aussi c'est des gros enjeux. et euh la
question aussi de la relocalisation de
nos systèmes de production qui inclut
qu'on le veuille ou non les mines. Parce
que relocaliser nos boucles
d'alimentation, relocaliser nos
monnaies, dire qu'on a des monnaies
locales, c'est sympa mais c'est bien de
dire qu'on va relocaliser notre
production d'énergie, très sympa. Mais
si c'est pour dépendre de métorares qui
sont extraits à 10000 km, ça n'a pas de
sens. Donc si je vais aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique, ça veut dire qu'il
faut que j'aille relocaliser mes mines
pour aller extraire des métorars
localement chez moi pour produire une
éolienne localement. Ça va très loin
cette notion de localisation, de
relocalisation et ça aussi il faut y
réfléchir et bien évidemment après la
question des modes de consommation est
fondamental et je crois que là-dessus
aussi euh euh nous sommes qu'au début de
ces questions qui sont vertigineuses.
Mais donc je voudrais vraiment insister
sur le fait que moi je suis un citoyen.
Euh je constate et je tombe de ma chaise
quand je vois tous ces constats là. Je
les ramène de bonne fois humblement en
essayant de vous montrer les chiffres
les plus officiels qui soit.
Ça veut pas dire que j'ai envie de
rester confortable confortablement dans
l'âge d'avant. J'ai envie d'avancer et
si les choix technologiques qui ont été
engagés il y a une dizaine d'années, une
quinzaine d'années, une trentaine
d'années avec cette transition
énergétique s'accélère et nous
permettent quand même effectivement un
peu moins d'émission de CO2, et bien
dans ce cas-là, allons-y. Mais encore
une fois, il y a des des des choix
beaucoup plus courageux à faire que ce
qu'on a fait pour faire de cette
transition un succès si tentait qu'elle
puisse être un succès.
Question d'internet. Oui. Bos d'eau.
Euh, monsieur Pitron, a-t-il des
exemples de pays dans le monde qui
prennent une direction exemplaire sur
ces sujets et sur lesquels nous
pourrions prendre exemple ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs façons de penser
décision exemplaire. Euh si je dois
prendre un exemple pour un pays qui
prend des décisions exemplaires en
matière économique de Greentech de de
d'emploi vert, j'irai en Chine parce que
la Chine, je sais que votre question
c'est sur l'écologie mais j'y réponds
quand même d'un point de vue économique.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, il y a un
pays développé dans enfin quasiment
développé. La Chine est pas un pays
seulement en voie de développement. un
une grande puissance aujourd'hui qui
pense le temps long, c'est la Chine et
la Chine est capable de penser à 10 20
ans 30 ans. 10 20 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans.
Et donc aujourd'hui si je devais prendre
un pays qui de façon exemplaire applique
une stratégie industrielle
pour gagner la bataille des emplois
verts, des technologies vertes et tirer
profit de cette transition à son
avantage d'un point de vue économique et
géopolitique, je dis c'est en Chine
qu'il faut aller. Ensuite, sur le plan
environnemental,
en fait,
j'ai l'impression que une partie de des
choses se passe
dans la frugalité et dans la sobriété et
qu'il y a des pays qui rigoler
châon et licorne. Non, mais il y a des
pays qui sont intéressants parce que euh
si vous voulez aujourd'hui, je je pense
notamment aux questions numériques euh
parce qu'ils sont qui sont liés aux
questions énergétiques, hein, puisque
les smart city c'est de l'énergétique et
du numérique. Euh on a quand même besoin
d'aller vers euh une simplification de
nos euh modèles de consommation
numérique. Et il y a en Inde et dans
certains pays d'Afrique certains
exemples de plus grande sobriété de nos
consommation de cette technologie là par
rapport au grand n'importe quoi, à la
grande gabie qu'on peut trouver en
Occident. Donc OK, je vous ai fait une
réponse un peu un peu un peu facile,
si pertinente qu'un filet d'eau tiède.
Donc en fait je vais me taire parce que
dans ce cas-là, c'est pas la bonne
réponse à donner.
Non mais non mais j'ai pas Non mais en
réalité c'est queil y a pas aujourd'hui
tout le monde veut la croissance. Voilà.
Donc à moins d'aller en Somalie et de
dire effectivement
c'est comme ça que ça devrait se passer
parce que voilà. Non, en réalité tout le
monde veut la croissance et il y a pas
des pays qui prennent une direction
nécessairement différente. Mis à part
quelques exemples intéressants. Ouais
mais le bouton c'est un truc de
journaliste, ça. Excusez-moi. Le bonheur
national. Bon tout le monde est allé
là-bas, tout le monde a parlé du bonheur
national brut. Tout le monde a dit que
c'était génial.
J' cette réponse. C'est un truc de
journaliste. Je suis je suis très
méfiant en fait. Je suis très méfiant
sur cet exemple là. euh le bouton euh je
ne connais pas le le le tarif du euh du
visa pour aller euh pour aller euh
voilà, aller là-bas et donc je veux dire
tout pays et est dans quelque chose
d'autre. Là où je prenais les exemples
de frugalité, même si ce mot est un peu
bisounours, c'était de dire qu'il y
avait aussi des exemples qui venaient de
l'innovation inversée et je trouve que
ces concepts d'innovation inversé sont
intéressants.
Autre question d'internet. Est-il
souhaitable de lancer l'extraction à
grande échelle des terrares en France ?
Ouais. Quelle est la situation actuelle
de l'Aval de la filière en France compte
tenu du monopole chinois sur les
matières premières ?
Ouais.
Rodi à la Rochelle ayant quasi mis la
clé sous la porte en 1998.
Ouais. Alors euh d'abord euh
question de l'épaule.
D'abord je je j'insiste et je le dis
avec
provocation et délectation. Ouvrir des
mines en France, c'est la décision la
plus écolo qu'on puisse prendre parce
que soyons clair, soit je continue à
faire l'autruche en laissant toutes ces
matières premières extraites à l'autre
bout du monde et puis je me vente de
faire ma transition écolo, soit je
relocalise mais ça va se faire selon des
critères français des réglementations
françaises avec un contrôle de la
société civile et des journalistes
et avec des prix français
et avec des prix français. Comptez sur
moi et enfin compter sur moi sur
l'aspect journalistique. Donc ça veut
dire que l'industriel qui veut faire qui
veut extraire autant de terre rar en
France qu'en Chine, ça va pas se passer
aussi facilement que si jamais il avait
les mains libres en Chine. Et donc vous
aurez du minerais plus propre ou en tout
cas moins sale et donc vous aurez les
technologies vertes moins sales. Et donc
en fait c'est une excellente décision
économique écologique pardon que de
décider d'ouvrir des mines en France
parce que ça nous permit permettrait de
limiter l'impact écologique de nos
technologies vertes et on pourrait tout
à fait le faire. On n' pas tous les
métaux mais on en a. On peut à
l'extraire du Tinstel en France, des
terres rares et en Europe, on trouve
également des gisements de terres rares
de lithium. On a découvert aussi des
gisements de lithium en France. Et donc
en fait, on pourrait produire une partie
de nos besoins. Je dis pas tout, mais on
pourrait tout à fait s'y mettre. Et je
pense que c'est aussi un enjeu de
justice que de dire qu'on se partage le
fardeau avec les pays pauvres qui se
dégueulassent leur environnement pour
qu'on puisse acheter des iPhone 11 à je
ne sais combien d'euros. L'aval de la
filière pour vous répondre l'aval de la
filière des technologies vertes, faut
regarder filière par filière. La filière
photovoltaïque,
il y a quasiment plus aucun emploi
industriel aujourd'hui dans le secteur
photovoltaïque en France, mis à part
Photow, peut-être quelques autres. En
gros, tous ces emplois sont partis en
Chine et aujourd'hui les emplois qui
restent dans le secteur des du des
panneaux solaires, c'est des emplois de
maintenance et d'installation de
panneaux solaires, mais pas des emplois
industriels de fabrication de panneaux
solaires ou en tout cas très peu
d'emplois. La Chine a tout trosté.
Ensuite, si vous voulez regarder la
batterie par exemple, c'est pas
brillant. Aujourd'hui, l'essentiel de
nos constructeurs automobiles français
ont besoin de batterie pour leurs
voitures électriques. Mais ces
batteries, elles sont fabriquées en
Corée du Sud ou en Chine. Euh donc c'est
pas brillant non plus. Alors
aujourd'hui, le président Macron dit il
faut qu'on on peut pas accepter cela. Il
faut un Airbus de la batterie, il faut
qu'on mette plein de milliards d'euros
pour pouvoir relancer une industrie
européenne de la batterie pour pouvoir
avoir nos propres batteries. Mais ça va
prendre quand même pas mal de temps
avant qu'on puisse rattraper notre
retard par rapport au Chinois. Vous avez
évoqué l'exemple la la l'aspect
Rpoulink. L'aspect Run Poulink, il vient
se glisser entre la mine et le produit
fini puisque Run Poulin en fait c'est le
le raffinage.
Run Poulin devenu Rodia et aujourd'hui
Roldia c'est Solvet. Mais aujourd'hui
euh Solvet avec sa branche Terrar à la
Rochelle, elle existe toujours euh mais
elle tourne à moindre régime que elle a
pas fermé en 98 hein. Les activités ont
simplement été pour partie délocalisé en
Chine. Les activités de raffinage
existent toujours mais sur un segment
moins polluant qu'à l'époque et donc
c'est les emplois qui sont perdus. Et
donc aujourd'hui la France n'a plus
leadership du raffinage des terres rares
comme elle pouvait l'avoir dans les
années 80-90. Ce leadership est parti
bien évidemment vers la Chine. Donc on a
sur l'aval de la filière des terres
rares les conséquences de nos choix
économiques. Et comprenez bien euh
pleurer sur les emplois sur la
désindustrialisation qui a été agencée
par la Chine, c'est ce leurer. C'est
nous qui avons décidé de nous
désindustrialiser. C'est la France qui a
fait ce choix et les plus occidentaux
qui ont fait ce choix de délocaliser la
pollution mais du coup de délocaliser
les emplois, les industries qui avaient
qui avec et qui étaient salissant. et
nous pleurons sur le lait renversé mais
nous sommes responsables de ce lait
renversé. Ce sont nos choix écologiques
et donc économiques et donc industriels
qui ont poussé à cette situation de
désindustrialisation
de euh du tissu économique français tel
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui.
En terme de fiscalité, vous voyez des
solutions ?
Comment ? J'essaie de comprendre votre
question.
Bah imaginez-vous on parle de taxe
carbone, non ? une taxe carbone ou une
fiscalité beaucoup plus agressive si
c'est produit dans un pays où c'est un
peu trop sale. Bah moi je suis à fond
pour je suis à fond pour la taxe carbone
et j'applaudis dès demain lorsque Ursula
Vanerle
parle de taxe carbone parce que taxe
carbone ça veut dire qu'on va taxer à
l'entrée sur le territoire européen des
par exemple panneaux solaires des
panneaux solaires qui sont chinois et
qui ont été produits dans des conditions
dégueulasses
et en fait si jamais on n'est capable de
réajuster
à la hausse le prix de ces panneaux
solaires qui parce que ces panneaux sola
ont un bilan environnemental avant
d'arriver sur le territoire français
qu'il faut bien prendre en compte et que
cela permet de rendre éventuellement
notre secteur de production de panneaux
solaires d'un point de vue industriel un
peu plus compétitif. Moi, je suis pour
et donc ça peut valoir pour tout et donc
je crois à la nécessité d'un
réajustement de ce niveau-là de sorte
que effectivement cette finalement cette
mesure antidumping permette et bien de
relancer ce qui peut être relancé en
matière de production locale de ce type
de technologie. Donc, j'applaudis à
demain sur la question de la taxe
carbone.
On est arrivé à la fin de notre
interview. Est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ?
Alors, trois livres à conseiller à votre
communauté.
Écoutez, j'aurais dû me préparer à cette
question. Donc, je vais dire trois
livres que j'ai récemment beaucoup aimé
que j'ai lu cet été. D'abord, cet été,
j'ai relu Barjavel. J'ai relu Bah oui,
mais c'est absolument merveilleux en
fait, Barjavel. et j'ai lu la nuit des
temps et j'ai j'étais embarqué dans ce
récit euh qui est la nuit des temps et
cette analyse que j'ai trouvé
intéressante des des des de la
complexité des ressorts humains. Donc je
je dirais un roman comme celui-ci. Euh
j'ai lu euh des essais récemment qui
m'ont euh euh intéressé. Euh j'ai lu un
livre sur le alors dont le nom le nom
l'auteur m'échappe mais sur le système
Tesla. C'est plus le toyotisme, c'est le
Teslisme. J'ai bien aimé ce et en fait
comment Tesla réinvente le toyotisme en
réorganisant en fait toutes ses chaînes
d'approvisionnement et tous ces modèles
économiques. Et j'ai trouvé que ce livre
aux éditions DU était très intéressant
parce qu'il permettait de comprendre
comment fonctionnent aujourd'hui les
grands géants de la Silicone Vallet,
quelle est leur vision économique de
leurs modèles économiques qui sont qui
qui sont des qui sont des visions qui
sont très intéressantes. Un dernier
livre que je vous conseillerai de lire,
que j'ai lu également, c'est un livre.
Alors, attendez, bah citons par exemple
Frédéric Bordage pour une société numé
pour une sobriété numérique. Je crois
que c'est le nom de son livre qui vient
de sortir aux éditions Bûchet Chastelle
sur la question de l'enjeu écologique
des technologies numériques et c'est
plein d'informations intéressantes sur
les ressorts de ces technologies là.
Voilà, ça répond, ça va un peu faire
suivre faire suite à ce qu'on vient de
se dire, mais c'est un sujet
intéressant.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Un conseil pour les génération les
jeunes générations. Euh je
je leur dirais que euh je leur dirai
d'avoir confiance. En fait, je je sais
que c'est paradoxal ou que ça peut
paraître paradoxal, mais je suis aussi
conscient que ce discours médiatique
actuel peut générer une forme d'hyper
inquiétude et peut-être une forme
d'hystérie. Euh et je
pense néanmoins que
j'ai j'ai je suis pas pessimiste de
nature, pas du tout. Et même si je vous
dis ce que je vous dis, euh je reste
pour autant euh confiant dans certaines
capacités de l'homme à réagir euh même
au pied du mur, mais à trouver des
solutions qu'elles soient technologiques
ou non technologiques, sociétale,
politique. Et donc, j'ai 15 ans
aujourd'hui, j'arrive dans ce monde-là
qui est un monde particulièrement
angoissant. Euh pour autant, je dis euh
il y a des belles choses qui vont
arriver. Il y a des belles choses. La
science, il faut croire en la science.
Il faut aussi croire en la science. Elle
va nous apporter des tas de solutions
absolument extraordinaires. Elle va
générer de nouveaux problèmes, c'est
sûr. Il faut croire aussi à la bonté de
l'homme qui au-delà de sa cupidité et de
son et de de son attrait pour l'argent
est capable aussi de de de deer
au service de sa survie et de sa
résilience. Et donc il y a des il y a
des choses excessivement intéressantes
qui qui vont se produire dans les 20
prochaines années. Un prochain livre
absolument à lire, un livre de Micho
Kaku. Micho Kaku KU aux éditions, je
crois que c'est Flamarion et ça
s'appelle une brève histoire du futur ou
de l'avenir de Michel Kaku. Et en fait,
c'est un livre sur tout ce que la
science annonce dans les 10 20 30 40 50
70 prochaines années dans tous les
domaines. Vous avez envie de vivre 150
ans quand vous lisez ce livre. Les
progrès de la médecine, les progrès de
l'exploration spatiale, les progrès de
nos systèmes énergétiques, même si on
s'est dit ce qu'on s'est dit, sont des
progrès absolument fabuleux. La science
des matériaux. Lisez ce livre pour avoir
confiance et vous dire que les
prochaines années, les prochaines
décennies seront également difficiles
mais réjouissantes et aussi
enthousiasmantes.
Guillaume Pitron, merci.
Merci à vous. Merci de m'avoir invité.
Le plaisir partagé.
[Musique]